[Musique]
amis du samedi soir
bonsoir bienvenue sur le plateau de
cette émission spéciale consacré au 10e
anniversaire de la disparition de Serge
ginzebourg nous allons vous raconter ce
soir en première partie de soirée le
Serge auteur compositeur interprète à
travers ses plus belles chansons
interprèt êé par les plus grands
artistes en deuxème partie de soirée
nous parlerons de ginsbourg peintre
écrivain auteur acteur réalisateur mais
aussi séducteur et night cluber et en
troème partie de soirée nous verrons
Serge ginsbourg sur scène c'est la nuit
ginsbourg c'est sur France 2 je fais des
trous des petits trous encore des petits
trous des petits trous des petits trous
toujours des petits
[Musique]
trous
plais en dansant là j'
venis
couleur
café que j'aime ta couleur café l A E
dans l' t I t I a Annie aime les
suettes les suettes à la
Nua Elisa ellisa saute-moi au coup
ellisa il faut que tu me explique un peu
mieux comment te dire adieu j'espère que
tu aimes c'est assez
[Musique]
bonant je ne reconnais plus père Harley
Dav je suis venu te dire que je m'en
[Musique]
vais tes larmes n pourront rien
changer
toi petite c'est sûr que tu
es allons enfants de la
Patrie le jour de gloire est arrivé je
pense à toi en tant que cible un bel
enfant
écartel c'est un Rubin c'est une
hpopodame avec un comme
[Musique]
marshmallow ch qui n jamais connu
TR avec moi ce soir à mes côtés le plus
grand gbourologue du monde l'auteur de
cet ouvrage Gill verland bonsoir thry
bonsoir tout le monde Gill verland
biographe préféré de de ginsbourg et on
va en avoir la preuve tout de suite Gill
que faisait Serge ginsbourg l'année de
ma naissance par exemple en 1949 1949
ginsbourg a 20 ans ginsbourg fait son
service militaire ouais ça c'est ce
qu'on a dit à la répète le le 6 janvier
49 le jour de jier 49 oui ça c'est plus
dur là 6 janvier 49 il le service
militaire ça l'enchante moyennement donc
il fa d'avoir une grippe donc il se il
est à l'infirmerie il énerve beaucoup
ses camarades de chambrée en jouant de
la guitare tout le temps mais il fait
aussi plaisir aux mêmes camarades de
chambr parce que c'est déjà un très bon
dessinateur et il leur fait des petits
dessins cochons ça leur plaît beaucoup
ça comme vous voyez G est un tarif sable
sur
ginbourg alors on va dans cette première
partie de dans cette première partie de
soirée on va parler de ginsbour auteur
compositeur interprète en cinq tableaux
qui correspondent à cinq époques de sa
vie première époque les années galères
de 1958 à 1964 ginsbourg est débutant il
démarre sa carrière à 30 ans donc c'est
pas un jeune débutant non plus et il
écrit d'entré de jeu des très grandes
chansons le poinceneur des Lila l'eau à
la bouche la javanaise deuxème partie
les années popes
1965 1968 là ginsbourg virire sacuti et
il vend des disques non pas sous son nom
mais par interprète interposé c'est par
exemple l'époque de poupé de TI poupé
son France Gal les années Birkin 1969
1977 ça correspond donc à sa à sa grande
histoire d'amour avec Jane et puis à des
grands albums qui s'appelit Histoire de
Melody Nelson l'homme à tête de chou
magnifique les années régés 78 81 il
chante aux armes et cetera il fait
scandale avec sa marseillaise Reger
ouais et les années funky pour finir en
1982 jusqu'à sa mort en 1991 il joue
avec des musiciens New Yorkais donc
c'est le son rock le son funky de
ginsbourg qui triomphe au casino et et
aux zénites également on commence par
les années
galèes alors on va commencer avec les
années galères de gbourg
1964 alors d' la famille ginbourg alors
Joseph
et
HT Russ et juif ils ont qué la Russie à
cause de la révolution bolchique ils ont
débarqué à Marseille en 1921 puis ils se
sont installés à à Paris le papa est
pianiste de jazz il est pianiste
d'orchestre pianiste dans les cabarets
également donc il initie très tôt le
petit Lucien Ginsburg futur Serge
ginsbourg il initie très tôt au piano
alors à 12 ans bah c'est 1940 puisquil
est en 28 c'est la guerre il disait
toujours qu'il avait porté une étoile de
shérif la famille ginsbourg est obligée
de se cacher euh en vers 43 44 ils
partent même du côté de Limoge ils
partent assez tard finalement ouais il y
a eu la rafle du veldive et cetera donc
ils ont échappé en fait il ils ont
traversé la guerre sans trop d'encombre
si ce n'est évidemment la peur au
quotidien alors qu'est-ce qu'il fait
ginsbourg après la guerre euh il se fait
virer d'abord du lycée il n'a jamais eu
son bac ginbourg il se fait virer peu
avant son 17e anniversaire euh donc il
négocie avec son papa et sa maman parce
que un échec scolaire pour pour les
ginsbourg c'est terrible donc il négocie
aussi avec son papa et sa maman donc il
s'inscrit en architecture au beauard euh
parce qu'il s'intéresse déjà beaucoup à
la peinture également il rêve de devenir
peintre en réalité c'est ça sa première
grande passion il veut faire de la
peinture mais comme il faut bien croûter
comme il faut bien survivre euh il joue
de la guitare dans des dans des
balloches il joue du piano aussi il
accompagne donc il commence à à jouer
dans des cabarets également il
accompagne d'autres chanteurs d'autres
chanteuses et peu à peu il abandonne la
peinture et il se il s'intéresse à cet
art mineur qui est la chanson et euh et
VO par rapport à cet art majeur qui est
la peinture qui est sa première vocation
il abandonne la peinture et il commence
à écrire des chansons à la fin des
années 50 mag Jérôme je suis le poneur
des l le gars qu'on croise qu'on regarde
pas il y a pas de soleil sous la
terreôle de croisière pour tuer l'ennui
j'ai dans ma veste les
extraits et dans ce bouquin il a écrit
queg la coule dou à
mi ant que je fais le zoive au fond de
la cave paraît qu'il y a pas de
sousmétier moi je fais des trous dans
les billè je fais des trous des petits
trous encore des petits trous des petits
trous des petits trous toujours des
petits trous des trous de seconde classe
des trous de première classe je fais des
trous des petits trous encore des petits
trous des petits trous des petits trous
toujours des petits trous des petits
des petits
trous écoute ma voix écoute écoute ma
prière écoute mon cœur qui va laisse-toi
faire je t'en prie ne sois pas
farouche quand me vient l'eau à la
bouche je te veux confiante je te sens
captive je te veux decile je te sens
craintive je t'en prie ne sois pas
farouche quand vient l' la
[Musique]
bouche cette
chanson les feuilles
mortes
s'fface de mon
souvenir et ce
jour-là mes amours
mes en aurons fini de mourir
et ce
jour-là mes amours
mortes en auront fini de
mourir voilà alors le point chneur des
Lila loit la bouche la chanson de
tréverre faut dire quand même qu'il
navait pas un physique très avenant et
ses chansons étaient pas très gay quand
même he oui et justement la critique à
l'époque salue l'arrivée d'un nouvel
auteur compositeur interprète ê vraiment
original vraiment différent et cetera
mais en même temps il ils disent avec
une gueule pareil il va avoir du mal et
effectivement il vend très peu de disqu
alors même qu'il enregistre ces
standards qui sont c'est devenu des
classiques de la chanson française alors
bonne critique mauvaise vente en 62
ginsbourg écrit interprète peut-être sa
plus belle chanson La Javanaise et ce
soir c'est Jin Berkin qui la
[Musique]
chante
j'avoue je n'ai bavé pas vous mon
amour avant d'avoir eu vend de vous mon
[Applaudissements]
amour
ne vous dé
[Musique]
plaise en dansant l'
vanè
nous nous
aimions le temps
d'une
chanson à votre vie qu'avons-nous vu de
l'amour de vous à moi vous m'avez eu mon
[Musique]
amour je vous
déplaise en dansant là
[Musique]
jaenis
nous nous
aimions le temps
d'une
[Musique]
chanson hélas avril en vain me vousoue à
l'amour
j'avais envie de voir en vous cet
[Musique]
amour ne vous
déplaise en dansant
[Musique]
là
nous nous
aimions le temps
du
CH
[Musique]
la vie ne vaut d'être vécue sans
amour mais c'est vous qui l'avez voulu
mon
amour
ne vous dé
plaise en dansant la
jvan
nous nous aimions
le temps
d'une
[Musique]
chansonise merci merci la bonne fé de
cette soirée sans qui rienurait été ible
alors la carrière de ginsbourg on est en
62 à peu près c'est l'arrivée du
l'arrivée du rock de la pop anglaise
l'arrivée des yyers et lui il est démodé
parce qu'il a un côté un peu chanteur
Rif gauche cabaret il est il est démodé
dès le début il décé ouais c'estàdire
que c'est vrai que les critiques quand
il est arrivé on ont vraiment salué
l'arrivée d'un auteur compositeur
différent et cetera mais il arrive trop
tard par rapport à toute la génération
des auteurs compositeurs interprètes des
années 50 les brelles les brassins les
bé les Aznavour les léopéré et c lui il
arrive ouais c'est ça
5 voilà et puis et puis et puis en fait
2 ans après qu'il démarre qu'est-ce qui
déboule en France les yy Johnny HID
Eddie Mitchell dceverers et toute la
bande et instantanément ginsbourg avant
même d'avoir pu prouver de quoi de quoi
il était capable il passe pour un un
hasbine et et c'est c'est ça qui est
dramatique alors qu'il écrit des
chansons sublimissimes non mais ce qui
était assez mignon avec ça tout de même
c'est que il y a tellement de gens qui
qui rappellent leur passé sans arrêt qui
vous enfin j'imagine qu'il y a des gens
qui remettent leurs anciens disques et
cetera ils voulaiit pas entend parler
moi j'ai jamais entendu la javenaise de
je dirais presque de son vivant c'est
pas tout à fait vrai parce que il a
repris pour le crisino de Paris mais
c'est vrai que il détestait sa voir
quand il chantait haut je pense qu'il a
accepté sa voix à partir le moment où il
a chantéich BBI et qu'il avait trouvé
cette méthode de un petit peu comme Rex
Harrison de chanter parler exactement et
avant il tout il faisit il faô truc avec
son quand il trouvait que ça ça
craignait sec quoi alors il a pas de
succès avec la chanson donc il fait du
cinéma et on verra ça dans la deuxème
partie de soirée c'est le ginsbourg
acteur de cinéma qui jouait dans des
pépelumes absolument
infames on est allé une fois à Pigal et
il fallait se cacher parce que les gens
faisaient hbou parce que il avait
toujours les noms en plus dégalassus les
noms comme ça parce qu' était toujours
en train de dire tuer les chrétiens et
cetera donc on partait de les cinémas
comme ça faut pas être ass pas les gens
en folie contre lui beaucoup de films
comme acteur à cette époque là
heureusement ginbourg a souvent été
sauvé par les femmes oui la première
femme qu'il sauve c'est Juliette Greco
Magneto
Jérôme j'avoue j'en ai BZ pas vous mon
amour avant d'avoir eu V de vous mon
amour
plaise en dansant la
javanise
nous nous aimions le temps du
né
ch à votre avis qu'avons-nous vu de
l'amour de vous à moi vous m'avez eu mon
amour
en
dans
[Musique]
javise nous nous
aimions qui a créé
laiseors
effementép je roule par terre he c'est
l'époque du Rock ginbourg est un peu
figé sur scène il est il est assez
hiératique et il a la révélation quand
il voit Boris Vian parce que finalement
il se dit que Boris Vian pareil il
chante tout droit sans sans bouger Boris
Vian qui composait des chansons
formidables comme comme chnob on n pas
là pour se faire engueuler on n pas là
pour se faire engueuler et tant d'autres
et le déserteur surtout il avait vu
Boris Vian sur scène et Boris Vian était
tétanisé par le trac il était paralysé
il était raide comme la justice serré
dans son petit dans son petit veston son
petit costume et et ginsbourg en le
voyant s'est dit mais il y a peut-être
moyen de faire quelque chose dans dans
ce domaine là dans le domaine de la
chanson et c'est c'est vrai que quand
ginsbourg commence sa carrière là tous
les témoins qui l'ont vu à l'époque qui
l'ont vu en 59 60 dans ses premiers
concerts il il il le confirme c'est
gensbourg était très très timide donc
très intimidé trackur à mort et très
souvent en tout cas quand il tournait
par exemple avec à la même la même
affiche que Jacques Brell ils ont fait
une tournée en province comme ça où il
était tout en bas de laaffiche Brell
évidemment était en tête d'affiche et
ben ça se passait très mal pour
ginsbourg il se faisait parfois huer par
le public est-ce que di est-ce que Serge
vous parlait de cette époque CIT assez
traumatisant pour lui parce que il
faisait des scènes il était était sifflé
même une fois où barbara a été obligé de
monter sur scène pour lui dire pour dire
au public arrêtez-vous de le siffler
c'est Serge ginbourg est-ce qu'il vous
avait parlé de ça non il m'avait parlé
que qu'il fallait être modeste et qu'
une fois que où il pensait qu'il était
pas mal que quelqu'un lui a dit c'est
pas vous qui a
emporté le succès ce soir c'est Bobby la
pointe
ouais Serge ginsbourg dans ses chansons
raconte très souvent l'histoire d'un mec
rendu fou d'amour par une fille hein et
dans la chanson qu'on va écouter
maintenant son obsession se réduit aux
lettres du prénom de la fille en
question alain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
souchamb l A E dans la t I t I a l A E
dans la t I t I
a sur ma Remington
portative j'ai écrit ton nom léditien l
A E dans l' t I t I a
Létitia les jours qui se suivent hélas
ne se ressemble pas l A E dans la t I t
I a
c'est ma douleur que je cultive en
frappant ces huit lettres
[Musique]
làelle
A c'est une fleur bien
maladive je la touche du bout des doigts
l a dans la t I t I
a s'il faut aller à la
dérive je veux bien y aller pour toi
l
dans
a ma raison en
définitive se perd dans ces huit lettres
là
[Musique]
dans sur ma Remington portative j'ai
écrit ton nom
[Musique]
l'édition
a
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour Gill ver le gbourologue
numéro 1 bonjour monsieur Souch bonjour
pourquoi avoir choisi
latitia ah
ben je la connais depuis toujours je
crois je sais pas je trouve absolument
extraordinaire de faire un truc aussi
non non mais un truc aussi bien avec si
peu de choses avec ce ce prénom et et pl
ça et ça fait un truc formidable qui
restera toujours parce que c'est c'est
vraiment tellement comme un bijou quoi
quand vous étiez ados ça signifiait quoi
pour vous Serge ginbourg ça me faisait
penser à à ce qu'avait fait à la même
démarche que Charles traet qui a une
certaine époque avait assimilé les
rythmes et les les ambiances musicales
anglo-saxones et qui en avait fait un
truc très Françis en même temps et très
poétique et très fort et et gansbur
c'est pareil c'est quelqu'un qui a
assimilé absolument ce qu'il fallait
assimiler dans le jazz dans le rock et
tout et qui en a fait un truc très
français avec de la des chansons très
poétiques comme on aime que ce soit en
France vous avez un truc en commun avec
vous avez un truc en commun non non
c'est pas des conneries du tout vous
avez un truc en commun avec ginsbourg
c'est qu'au départ on peut pas dire vous
soyez un physique très facile et les
femmes vous adorent rigolez vous rigolez
mais comment vous expliquez
ça les femmes nous
adorent c'est pour ça qu'on fait ces
métiers là c'est pour que les femmes
nous remarquent je sens qu'elle nous
adore au moins que qu'elle nous voit
ouais je P enfin pour moi je sais pas
lui être pareil non tous les garçons qui
font ses métiers vous ça doit être
pareil de se montrer comme ça c'est pour
filles si
sûrment alors g à
l'époque Serge bon il arrive pas tout
seul en tant qu'auteur compositeur
interprète donc il écrit pour les autres
il fait chanter ses ses chansons par
d'autres Brigitte bardau bardau il écrit
un rock pour elle l'appareil Assous et
puis Juliette Greco donc pour compose
oui pour qui compose une autre chanson
qui est devenue un standard de la
chanson française même au niveau
international et qui est qui s'appelle
accordéon accordé accordé don l'omone à
l'accordéon Magnetto
Jérôme musicien des r son copain son
compagnon
qui vivre à s'asseir quand il s c'est
vous c'est
moi c'est
[Musique]
l'accordéonordéon
tu n'es qu'un appareil à
soupire un appareil à sourire à ce jeu
je ne joue pas je n'aime pas cette opéra
de quatre soupire C TER que tu as de
sourire je ne pourais qu'en
souffrir on ne gagne que des gros soup
à vouloir
sansouvir tout ce jeu ne sa quoi d'im
mal en soi qui nous fait prendra tous
nos
soupirs je te dis ça sans sourire je ne
P en
[Musique]
rou
voilàinbourg véritable Frégoli on va
écouter maintenant une une autre chanson
de la même époque qui avait été créée
par lui qui a été reprise par Catherine
den en 1981 et par Jan dans version Jan
ce soir c'est François hardardi qui la
chante voici c'estes petit rien mais
avant je voudrais dire au revoir Alain
Souchon qui va nous quitter au revoir
merci d'être venuci
merci françoisard c'est petit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rien
mieux vaut ne penser à rien que ne pas
penser du tout rien c'est déjà rien
c'est déjà
beaucoup on ne se souvient de rien et
puisqu'on oublie
tout rien c'est bien mieux rien c'est
bien mieux que
tout mieux faut ne penser à rien que de
penser à vous ça ne me vaut rien ça ne
me vaut rien du
tout mais comme si de rien n'était je
pense à tout c'est petit rien qui me
venait de
vous si c'était trois fois rien trois
fois rien entre
nous évidemment ça ne fait pas
beaucoup ce sont ces petits riens que
j'aiis pour à vous c'est petit rien qui
me venait de vous de vous mieux faut
pleurer de rien que de rire de
tout pleurer pour un rien c'est déjà
beaucoup mais vous vous n'avez rien dans
le cœur et
j'avou je vous envie je vous en veux
beaucoup ce sont ces petits riens qui me
venaient de vous les vousoulez-vous tenz
que
voulez-vous moi je ne veux pour rien au
monde plus rien de vous pour être à vous
faut être à moitier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fou merci
beaucoup
françoisard
merci Françoise à l'époque vous
rencontrerez ginsbourg plus tard mais à
l'époque ça signifie quoi pour vous
Serge ginsbourg parce que tellement plus
le style r gauche ou le style chanson
française traditionnelle alors que moi
j'appartiens à cette génération qui a
été
complètement séduite par par Elvis
Presley par par toute cette par le RO
par le rock en fait hein donc donc Serge
à cette époque là c'était effectivement
autre ch nouvelle vague je dir d'abord
que c'est
moi parce que qui est nouvelle vague ve
dire qui est à l'avant-garde de la
chansonxxx jeque
desxant c'est la vague nouvelle
qu'est-ce que vous appelez la vague
nouvelle c'est chanson am
et vous croyez au
y
comment sous
[Musique]
les je feris du Ram Dam je me connais
oui à Sing Sing je
finirai j'ai un coupe coupe à
grandarrê non rien naura raison de moi
j'irai chercher ma Lolita che les
[Musique]
y j'aime ta couleur
café tes cheveux cafés ta gorge
café j'aime quand pour moi tu danses
alors j'entends murmurer tout t
bracelet joli
Brasselet à tes pieds il se balance
couleur
café que j'aime ta couleur
[Musique]
café couleur
café
alors à cette époque là ginbourg
s'installe sur le créneau de la
misogynie non c'est-à-dire fait des
chansons assez dur pour les filles oui
très agressive dès ses premières
chansons en 58 en fait c'est ça il prend
une posture agressive vis-à-vis des
femmes la la la pire dans dans le genre
c'est en relisant ta lettre oui mais
c'est celle qu'on va entendre alors ça
c'est terrible donc c'est une fille qui
écrit à à Serge enfin au chanteur de la
chanson en tous les cas et qui lui fait
part de son intention de se suicider et
lui au lieu d'être touché par cette
lettre évidemment ça devrait lui fendre
le cœur il corrige les fautes
d'orthographe alors on va l'écouter
avant je voudrais saluer Jane vous nous
quittez un petit moment vous revenez
tout à l'heure parce les Ann Berkin
quand même là à tout de suite donc ça
s'appelle
ça s'appelle en relisant ta lettre et
c'est Alain chanfort qui la
[Musique]
chante en lisant ta lettre je m'aperçois
que l'orthographe et toi ça fait deux
c'est toi que j'aime ne prend qu'un aim
par-dessus
tout
ne me dis point il en manque un que tu
t'en
fous je t'en supplie point sur le i
fais-moi
confiance je suis l'esclave sans accent
grave des
[Musique]
apparen c'est ridicule c'est majuscule
c'était si
bien tout ça m'a fait
ça c'est correct au plus haut
point si tu renonces comme ça se
prononce à
m'écouter avec la vie comme ça s'écrit
j'en
finirai pour me garder ne prends qu'un
des tant de
rancune tuas pas de cœur il y a pas
d'erreur là il y en a
une j'en mourirai n'est pas français ne
comprends-tu
pas ça sera ta faute ça sera ta faute
bah là il y en a
pas moi je te signale que
gardénal ne prends pas
deux mais n'en prends qu'un caché au
moins
n'en prends pas
deux ça te calmera et tu verras tout
retombe à
l'au il cafare les pleurs les peines de
cœur au e dans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'eau qu'est-ce que c'est bien écrit
hein c'est incroyablement bien écrit ou
oui et et et dessous ce cynisme apparent
et cette misogénie on on on devine quand
même un personnage un cœur qui souffre
oui enfin tu quelqu'un de meurtri et et
et je trouve que ce que j'aimais c'était
pas par provocation qui faisait ça
c'était plus par pudeur j'ai
l'impression que lui pour lui dire je
t'aime c'était quelque chose de
complètement indescent et que à cette
époque- làà il est il y avait un truc
vraiment authentique qui passait lui
alors vous avez travillé ensemble on y
revient viendra d'ailleurs plus tard
dans l'émission vous a travillé ensemble
avec Serge ginzebourg bien plus tard à
la fin des années 70 pour le moment on
est on termine les années galères hein
mon cher Gill verland ça ça va beaucoup
mieux se passer pour ou on va passer au
deième tableau ça va mieux se passer il
arrête de faire des concerts parce que
de toute façon ça le déprime plus
qu'autre chose une dernière tournée en
première partie de Barbara c'est ce
solde par un désastre complet et
justement il y a des interprètes qui
commencent à lui demander des chansons
et des interprètes qui commencent
surtout à vendre des disques c'est ce
qu'on va voir voir ça avec le deuxè
tableau de notre ginbourg story bah
écoutez à tout à l'heure de toute façon
vous allez revenir pour parler de tous
les chefdœuvres que vous avez fait
ensemble sur des musiques de vous
d'ailleurs souvent Françoise vous restez
avec nous on passe au deuxème
tableau
voilà donc on passe aux années pop
1968 alors ben à l'époque il quitte le
cabaret hein ouais absolument et surtout
ça va être une période incroyablement
prolifique pour gansburg qui va composer
et écrire des dizaines de chansons il va
et peut-être des chansons plus simples
et plus percutantes ou il va virer sa sa
cuti commerciale mais commerciale à la
manière de ginsbourg c'est-à-dire
toujours sophistiqué c'està dire
toujours décalé toujours au second degr
c'est ce qu'on va voir est-ce qu'on peut
pas dire qu'il est touché aussi par la
force libératrice des des années 60
c'est-à-dire que il se met à sourire il
se laisse un peu pousser les cheveux
enfin il est moins austère que dans les
moins après guerre que dans les années
50 oui surtout surtout lui qui justement
était un musicien quand même très séduit
par le jazz et cetera et ben tout à coup
quand même il se laisse avoir par le
charme du rythme binaire des chansons
rock des Beatles et tous les autres
alors il connait beaucoup de succès
comme d'habitude avec des interprètes
féminines on va le voir mais d'abord une
chanson qu'il a chanté lui qui est
interprétée par fudel le petit prince du
rail c'est Elisa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Elisa ellisa ellisa ellisa saute-moi au
coulisa
ellisaisa cherche-moi tes Bou enfonce
bien tes ongles et tes doigts
délicats dans la jungle de mes cheveux
Elisa ellisa Élisa Élisa saute-moi au
cou Élisa Élisa Élisa cherche-moi des
Bou fais-moi quelques anglaises et Laé
au milieu on a 13 14 ans nous de ellisa
Élisa Élisa les autres on s'en fout
Élisa Élisa Elisa rien que toi moi nous
mes 20 ans tes 40 si tu crois que
cela me
tourmente ah non vraiment
[Musique]
L
Élisa Élisa Élisa saute-moi au cou Élisa
Élisa Élisa cherche-moi des P enfonce
bien tes ongles et tes doigts
délicats dans la jungle de mes
[Musique]
cheveuxaa ela
Eliza
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
beaucoup bien Faudel pourquoiisa ah
envoyé l'album on m'a dit de choisir et
puis je l'ai trouvé vraiment superbe
simple et justement je pouvais mettre
quelques mélopés folkloriques voilà
ouais alors première chansons de
ginsbourg vous avez entendu c'est quoi
moi le le le enfin ce qui m'a attiré
c'est son côté provoque c'est pas le
côté ginsbourg c'est ginsbar qui m'a
attiré et donc c'est quand j'ai vu
j'étais j'avais quoi 8 ans je crois
quand j'ai vu quand il a brûlé le fameux
le billet de voilà 7/ 7 un Saré Scand et
j'ai dit à ma maman mais attends maman
tu as vu il a brûé le billet et donc
c'est ce qui m'a interpellé ou B on va
parler ça sera notre notre dernierre
notre dernier tableau ça sera
effectivement le papi funky ginbar euh
vous avez un pig Malion Faudel quelqu'un
qui qui gère votre carrière qui ah oui
bien sûr ah oui oui bien sûr je pense
qu'on peut pas enfin tout seul non je
suis pas homme d'affaires encore non
parce que gansbourg Serge ginbourg a été
le le PIG Malion de de France Gal il
disait même France Gal m'a sauver la vie
parce que donc on sort de ces années de
galère euh ginsbourg qui fait des albums
pointus qui ne se vendent pas et il y a
quand même un ange gardien enfin
quelqu'un en tout cas qui travaille avec
ginsbourg qui a la bonne idée de lui
dire mais et si tu rencontrais cette
petite France Gal qui vient de démarrer
elle a 16 ans elle a sorti un premier 45
tours elle a été immédiatement adoptée
par salut les copains et oui on va voir
poupée de cire poupée de son donc là
l'Eurovision et les sucettes sansang qui
a beaucoup fait parler Magneto
Jérôme jeis une poupée de c une poupée
de
S le gravé dans mes chansons poupé desir
poupé de
son suis-je meilleur suis-je pire qu'une
poupée de
salon je vois la vie en rose de bonbon
poupée de CIR poupée de son mes disques
sont un miroir dans lequel chacun peut
me
voir je suis part tout à la toire pr en
l'éclat de bois
sal parfois je soupire je me dis à quoi
B
chaninsi d'amour sans raison sans rien
connaître deses
garçons je ne suis qu'une coupée de cire
qu'une coupée de
sang sous le soleil de mes cheveux
blancs poup de pou de temp je me
souviens de avoir 3 ans vous m'avez dit
en parlant des très jeunes après tout
s'ils veulent acheter des wagons de
sucette ça les regarde de moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas il se trouve que
maintenant c'est vous qui leur fabriquez
les sucettes c'est même vous l'usine à
sucett
oh au gingemb les sucettes am aime
leses les su à
[Applaudissements]
la les sucettes à
la donne bais
unou
nu le
parfumé à la
nuit coule dans la gorge d'amie
elle est au
[Musique]
parti pour qu'el que
pé
ami assees
sucet
l' elles ont la couleur de ses grands
yeux la couleur des J
[Musique]
il y a pas de papier autour de mes
sucettes c'est tout voilà les sucette et
poupée de cire poupée de son alors
évidemment France Gal sauve la vie de de
Serge ginbourg puisque d'un seul coup il
a du succès il gagne de l'argent grâce à
ses ch poupé de son un imm succès à
travers toute l'Europe il y a même une
une version japonaise de poupée de cire
il en vend des millions d'exemplaires
ginsbourologue il sa tout c'est
extraordinaire il a écrit ça là tu lui
c'est tout là regarde
bien alors il y a d'autres interprètes
féminines il y a Régine il y a pétu
laaclarque al je sais pas si vous
souvenez encore de pétu laaclarque
c'était quelqu'un pétu la clarque dans
les années dans les années 60 c'était
une grosse vedette Anna Carina qui a
chanté évidemment on va le voir du
guinsbourg pour la comédie musicale de
pierre coralnque qui s'appelleait Anna
Anna absolument François hardardy on va
voir sous aucun prétexte enfin dans le
vrai titre est comment te dire adieu
comment te dire adieu on va voir les
interprètes féminines de Serge ginsbourg
et puis aussi un petit bout d'un d'une
interview d'une émission qui s'appelleit
Discorama c'était Denise Glazer qui
présentait é extraordinaire Denise
Glazer parce que extraordinaire elle
vous recevait puis elle disait elle
parlait pas comme ça puis au bout d'un
moment elle disait ça va vous terrible
voilà et c'est dans cette fameuse
interview que ginsbourg lance pour la
première fois cette phrase qui fera
floress c'est j'ai retourné ma veste et
j'ai découvert qu'elle était doublée de
vison Magnetto Jérôme pourquoi avez-vous
retourné votre blouse ma veste ma veste
je fais 12 titres moi sur ces 12 titres
deux passent sur les antennes et les 10
autres sont parfaitement ignorés j'écris
12 titres pour 12 interprètes différents
et les 12 sont 12
succès du MO de septembre au moin
d' pour des btes de
C pour per dans
[Musique]
l'ououou
une une les gouttes
d'eau mais des goulines dans le
dos nous partons dans
[Musique]
l'adouadouadouadouadouou sous le soleil
exactement pas à côté pas n'importe où
sous le soleil sous le
soleil exactement juste en
dessous
laissez parler les petits papier à
l'occasion papier chiffon puiss-il un
soir papier buvard vous
consolz
laissz brûler les petits papiers papier
de riz ou
d'Arménie qu'un soir il puisse papier
maïs pour rchauffer sous aucun prétexte
je ne veux avoir de réflexes
malheureux il faut que tu m'expliques un
peu mieux comment te dire
adieu mon cœur de silex V tout
profond ton cœur de pex résiste auond je
suis bien perplexe je ne peux me
résoudre aux à dieux
je sais bien qu'un
ex amour n'a pas de chance aussi
peu mais pour moi une
exlication
[Musique]
voilà alors
Françoise cette chanson on l'a tellement
entendu par Jimmy Somerville qu'on avait
oublié qu'elle était aussi jolie cette
chanson ah oui ah oui elle est tellement
plus belle par vous vraiment oh ah si si
alors dises-moi très gentil pour Jimmy
Summerville de dire ça ah mais je
préfère François que Jimmy sumille ça je
dis franchement à la
télévision bien alors la la musique
était pas de la musique n'était pas de
de ser non c'est assez rare d'ailleurs
quand il a accepté de de d'écrire des
textes sur des musiques qui n'étaient
pas de lui ça voulait dire qu'il croyait
très fort dans les musiques au départ
c'est une musique amériain oui c'est un
instrumental que j'ai comme ça trouvé
tout à fait par hasard c'est vous qui
l'avez trouvé oui j'étais allée chez un
éditeur qui voulait absolument me placer
une chanson comme on dit et et en
désespoir de cause je suis partie avec
la seule chose qui m'est intéressé
pendant 2 heures d'écoute pas du tout
sûr d'ailleurs que j'allais retenir ça
vraiment et puis en récoutant je me suis
dit ah c'est pas mal et tout alors à
cette époque Serge ginbourg enregistre
aussi beaucoup de de musique de film euh
notamment la musique d'un film que tout
le monde connaît tout le monde adore
c'est le pachat de George lner avec Jean
Gabin dialogue de Michel odudiard c'est
là où il y a quand les mecs de 120 kg
parlent au mec de 60 kg mec de 60 kg
écoute enfin il y en a comme ça il y en
a plein de film des plus grandes répliqu
oui voilà une des plus grandes répliques
alors je vais vous dire adieu
euh je sors mon clinex voilà oui c'est
ça à bientôt Faudel aussi alors moi je
l'ai
rencontré et nous alors on va on va
regarder la musique du film Le Pacha ça
s'appelle REM pour un con et c'est
chanté par
Zaz
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoute les or le jour pour toi il est
terrible cette heure
làà j'espère que tu aimes c'est assez
beauon nom c'est le
Rouen pour un
con je l'ai composé spécialement pour
toi à ta mémoire
de
ser c'est un joli thème tu ne trouvvees
pas semblable à toi-même pauvre con
voici les gens qui remettent ça faut que
tuapprennes par cœur C
TER que tu n'es pas même une
hésitation sur le R aim toi
con quoi tu me regardes tu n'apprécies
pas qu'est-ce qu'il y a
làdedans qui te plaît
pas pour moi c'est idem que ça te plais
non je tejoue quand
même
[Musique]
con
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoute les
joue pour toi il est terrible cette
terre
là j'espère que tu aimes c'est assez bon
[Musique]
non je l'ai composé spécialement pour
toi à ta mémoire de
[Musique]
ser sur ta F blè au mur des prisons
j'inscrirai moi-même pauvre
[Musique]
con
merci merci beaucoup
jaasie merci merci beaucoup une belle
reprise une belle réinterprétation de
RAM pour un con qui est donc comme je
disais la musique du film Le Pacha c'est
pourquoi cette chanson parce que c'est
dire que là c'est parce que il l'a
composé en 67 je crois elle a été elle
est sortie en 68 faut demander au
ginbourologue he c'est ça précisément
c'est beau et et que c'est quand même il
le savait pas mais c'est quand même lui
qui a inventé le principe d'une séquence
de rythme qu'on retrouve dans la techno
dans la hausse musique maintenant la
boucle c'est lui qui l' qui l'a inventé
avec les Beatles aussi qui qui
tatillonnait voilà et puis il il y a une
histoire terrible avec ce morceau le
rm.c parce que d Jo s'était amusé à
remixer le REM pour un con et ça avait
beaucoup plu à ginbourg on est là en 90
et il s'était dit tiens ça serait ça
serait bien de ressortir leum pour un
con remixé et le disque est sorti la
veille de sa mort ah oui vous quelle
époque de votre vie vous l'avez
découvert ginbourg la décadence je
devais être quand même assez assez
petite et je comprenais rien du tout
mais je trouvais ça formidable mais je
ne panais pas un mot quoi je n'apprimais
rien du tout de ce qu'il disait et je me
disais c'est formidable de faire une
chanson s'appelle la décadence mais vous
avez aussi écrit deux chansons très très
belles qui sont directement inspirées
par Serge oui il y a je t'aimais qui est
un titre gincebouren s'il en est sur zen
en 95 avec je me Gince bar en fumée oui
bah c'est il il il pourrait le dire ou
oui il pourrait le dire c'està dire que
moi j'ai un problème c'est qu'à chaque
fois que je fais un texte heureusement
j'ai un copain qui m'a offert l'intégral
de de ginbourg parce que trois fois sur
4 quand c'est pas 9/ 10 je je suis très
fière je me suis vraiment saigné pour
toi un jeu de mot donc jeiste déjà et
ben ça c'est fait il est déjà pris donc
bon alors c'est l'époque Gilles du
Swinging London de carnob street c'est
c'est c'est ah ben on est tout à fait
dans les anées popes de ginsbourg on est
dans dans les années où il va à Londres
il va à Londres enregistrer ses disques
mais il lui aussi il chante et il se
métamorphose en chanteur pop et c'est à
l'époque où il enregistre qui est in qui
est out docteur Jacky et Mister Hyde et
comme Denise Glazer lui demande il se
prend pour les Beatles à lui tout seul
Magnetto
[Musique]
Jérôme
tu AES la
nitroglycér
[Musique]
c'estadip maintenant vous chantez un peu
comme un Beatles vous tout seul
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé il a un
courant mondial qui VI qui est né à
Liverpool et peut pas ben ignorer c'est
tout c'est très simple faut pas se
scléroser écoutter vraiment
JEC Marie il faut se montrer
patient c'est une petite
enfant qui ne m'écoute
pas as-tu déjà aimé
Mar aurais-tu essayé
Mar seraisje le premier
[Musique]
j'écris des chansons
difficiles on dit je suis un
intellectuel j'écris des chansons
faciles on dit je suis que je je
sacrifie au
commercial fe pas la paix quoi on
cherche des
noises non je ne suis pas le docteur
Jacob mon nom est HDE Mr
HDE
docteur avait en lui un Monsieur H qui
était son mauvais génie Mr HDE ne disait
rien mais en secret pens pas
moin je vous dis que je dis pas le
[Musique]
docteur mon nom est
h
quel caméléon ce gbour tous les styles
possibles imaginables je pense qu'à part
les Beatles il a pas quelqu'un qui a
fait autant de style de musique
différent dans sa vie est-ce qu'il vous
plaît le le ginbour de docte J est
misterde
euh oui moi je connais je connais plus
en fait celui d'après juste après que
j'aimais bien parce que je trouais qu'il
y avait les cheveux qui devenaient
carrément franchement longs et alors là
il avait un côté biten qui me plaisait
beaucoup mais vas-y est-ce qu'il est
devenu beau ginsbour ou on s'est habitué
à sa tête bon ça vous savez ça après
c'est l'immense débat sur la beauté des
gens moi j'ai toujours préféré les
gueules aux gens politiquement correct
avec un nez au milieu quoi donc lui je
trouve je le trouve extrêmement sexy en
plus c'est séduisant mais j'ai pas été
la seule donc vu le tableau de belles
femme qu'il a eu je pense qu'il y avait
pas de problème non il y a pas de
problème du tout on va parler de bardau
là c'est le moment justementchaînement
enchaînement réussi alors vous me
demandez bah ouis à l'époque bah Bardo
est une grande star de cinéma elle vit
avec un playboy allemand Gunter gunterx
qui elle l'a même épousé Gunter sax
Playboy international ouais qui est
hérité de la fortune Opel Opel ça aide
et alors elle a du succès dans la
chanson elle fait la Madrague absolument
mais elle prépare un un show qui doit
être diffusé le premier janvier 68 c'est
le show de nouvel an et bardau est à
cours de chanson donc elle fait appel à
quelqu'un qui lui a déjà écrit des
chansons quelques années auparavant
c'està-dire à ginsbourg et euh fait
l'appareil àous ce qu'on a vu tout à
l'heureou absolument et ginsbourg lui
offre d'entrée de jeu Davidson et Bardo
dit mais j'ai jamais fait de moto
pourquoi est-ce que vous m'écrivez cette
chanson et euh et ginbourg dit je sais
pas mais je trouve que voilà et puis
après l'enregistrement de Harley
Davidson on est en octobre
1967 ils vont dîner au restaurant et là
bardau craque pour ginsbourg et elle le
drague elle lui prend la main comme ça
discrètement sous la table et c'est le
début d'une histoire d'amour fulgurante
entre bardau et ginbourg qui va durer 2
mois et
demi le temps de faire de terminer cette
cette fameuse émission il enregistre
Davidson bon and comic ce est incroyable
c'est que lui l'artiste maudit
finalement il pique la plus belle femme
du monde un milliardaire en grande
revanche aussi ce contexte de l'UR qu'il
avait depuis toujours depuis
l'adolescence alors il enregistrera avec
bardau la première version de je t'aime
moi non plus qui n'est jamais sorti
parce que gunterx il voulait pas du tout
il avait les boules il avait les boules
mais en revanche le show du Nouvel An
aura beaucoup de succès c'était le 1er
janvier 68 Magneto Jérôme
VI petite fille dans mon VI
faire
[Musique]
faire ou
bien
par
ou chaque fois qu'un policeman se fait
buter qu'un garage au qu'une banque se
fait
braquer pour la police ça ne fait pas de
mystère c'est
sign bnny par B
[Musique]
and
je n'ai besoin de faire en Harley
davon je ne reconnais plus personne
Harley
Davidson je vais à plus de 100 et je me
sens à feu et à 100 que m'importe de
mourir les cheveux dans le
vent
que M porte de mourir les cheveux dans
le
[Musique]
vent
voilà Brigitte bardau interprétant du
Serge ginbourg alors ginbourg lui il
veut que cette histoire il veut que
cette histoire dure le petit hôtel
particulier de la rue de Verneuil où il
habitera après toute sa vie il va le
visiter la première fois avec avec
Brigitte bardau absolument il visite le
le petit é l'ensemble d'ailleurs il
voulait en faire un petit nid d'amour
pour Bardo et lui il pensait que cette
histoire d'amour allait allait durer et
puis voilà TIPA que Brigitte bardau doit
aller tourner un film à Almeria en
Andalousie absolument un NAET d'ailleurs
une espèce de de westne d'obé avec Chun
connerie alors voilà alors justement
donc loin des yeux loin du cœur bardau
se retrouve à Almeria elle craque en
fait sur un assistant du du tournage et
puis pas le portable à l'époque c'estàd
que pour appeler pour appeler c'était
compliqué quoi fallait d'AB la ligne
avant d'appeler pas le portable ginbour
est très affecté effectivement depuis
avoir de de nouvelles de Brigit Bau
parce que c'était quand même ça c'est
pas conta voilà il y avait pas de
contact pourtant il y avait eu la
chanson contact mais là il avait plus et
donc ginbour est très triste et il écrit
une chanson mais avant d'écouter cette
chanson je vais saluer Zaz merci d'être
venu
Zaz et à bientôt à
bientôt voilà et alors la chanson que
gbour écrit très triste c'est Bibi et
c'est chanté ce soir par
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
méléque une nuit que
j'étais à me
morfondre dans quelques pub anglais du
cœur de Londres parcourant l'amour
monondre de Poë
une vision dans l'eau de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sel
tandis que les médailles
d'impérator vont Brè à sa taille le
bronze et l'or le platine lui grave d'un
cercle proid la marque des esclaves à
chaque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
noire
[Musique]
jusqu'en haut des cuisses et les beauté
et c'est comme un calist à sa beauté
elle porte rien
d'autre qu'un peu des de
Guerlin dans les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cheveux
[Musique]
à chaque mouvement on entendait les
clochettes d'argent de ses poignets
agitant ses grelots
elle avança et prononça ce mot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alméia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ben
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bibi pourquoi cette chanson parce que
j'adore le groupe de cette chanson je
trouve qu'elle a un rythme incroyable et
comme je suis très ENF fan de sou et
j'adore vraiment le rythme de cette
chanson c'est votre chanson préférée de
ginbourg c'est ma chanson préférée
d'ailleurs j'ai voulu la sler et bon je
je ne l'ai pas fait mais ça vraiment ma
chanson préférée bah les rappeurs aiment
bien ginbour d'une façon générale parce
qu'il y a un jeu sur les mots sur les
sonorités sur les allitérations donc
c'est vrai Solar a souvent dit solar qui
qui est un peu votre mentor a souvent
dit le respect qu'il avait pour pour
Serge gbourg il a une manière d'écrire
très très particulière et puis il a
l'art d'amener le l'auditeur dans son
univers de de le faire voyager et cetera
c'est ce qu'on essaie aussi nous de
faire dans le rap initial bébé c'est un
des premiers morceaux où ginsbourg parle
ouais sur musique donc finalement est-ce
que c'est pas lui le précurseur du rap
en français c'est pas loin du rap ouais
disons quei c'est c'est un peu une une
façon de rapper ouais enfin c'est pour
ça que j'ai pu le reprendre aussi
facilement oui mais plus ça va on va le
voir d'ailleurs plus ça va plus
ginsbourg parle sur des rythmes au lieu
de chanter et ça ira quand qu
saacroissant cette tendance non
absolument bien benénéic merci merci
d'avoir été là pour cette version merci
à vous à bientôt alors on va passer
maintenant on va passer au 3è tableau
j'ai dit au début de l'émission il y
avait 5 tableaux on passe maintenant au
3è tableau les années birkines
1977 voilà la chaîne c'est France 2 la
soirée c'est la nuit ginbourg alors
prière partie de
ginbourg auteur compositeur interprète
deè partie de soirée l'autre ginsbourg
le Night cluber le séducteur l'écrivain
le peintre le réalisateur l'acteur et 3è
partie de soirée un concert et là on
commence les années Birkin donc c'est le
3è tableau de cette émission Jane est
revenu puisque ce tableau vous est
consacré à l'époque bah Serge est assez
malheureux Brigit bardau l'a quitté et
heureusement coup de bol et quand on
vous voit en comprend il rencontre
jenkin
alors c'est le film slogan c'est Pierre
grimbla qui vous a qui vous a réuni au
début ça se passe pas très bien entre
Serge et vous et un soir je sais pas si
c'est vrai mais un soir pierre grimbla
vous invite à dîner tous les deux il
vient pas pour vous laisser en tête à
tête c'est ça
l'histoire écoute on a tellement raconté
les trucs je ne sais plus ce qui était
vrai ou pas je crois que ce dîner a eu
lieu chez Régine je pense et puis le le
chose qui était vraiment jolie parce que
j'étais chez ses parents il était en
train de faire un un intervie à propos
de bardau il avait mis j'étais Mo non
plus sur son pickup donc on a bien
compris qu'il était un très grand
séducteur il y avait des photos de barde
grand de nature dans son appartement
alors je me suis dit oh là là mais alors
ce type de pour qui se prend et puis il
était un peu irrité parce que je
l'appelais Serge bourguignot je ne sais
pas pourquoi c'était le seul plat
français que je connaissais et il m'a
quand même filé un livre de ses poésies
qui s'appelait chanson cruelle je pense
pour montrer qu'il n'était pas n'importe
qui et puis après le le dîner avec grand
blage tout ce que je sais moi ce qui m'a
charmé c'est que lui qui avait l'air
d'être arrogant sûr de lui sfel
parfaitement parfaitement à l'aise quand
on dansait un slow ensemble il me
marchait sur les pieds et ça je trouvais
ça touchant je me suis dit en fait
peut-être qu'il sait pas danser et en
effet après ça il a fait le tourné des
Grands Ducs comme il disait et puis il
m'a emmené chez Madame Arthur un endroit
de travestie o où son son père était
pianiste dans le temps il m'a embarqué
pour voir rptine boî un boîte de nuit
russe génial et je me suis dit c'est pas
possible que ce type si charmant parce
que tous les traversis disaient oh
coucou sergou bisous je me suis dit mais
tout le monde l'adore en fait on croit
que c'est une crocodile mais pas du tout
et et après il m'a invité et à mon
chagrin c'est n'était pas d'aller
coucher chez ses parents ou de de les
rendre visite vers 4h du matin c'était
directos au à au Hilton alors là je me
suis dit oh je suis un peu rapide comme
fille quand même alors je regrettais un
peu mais en même temps je me suis dit Oh
quand même John Barry est parti ma
fiquette était dans l'hôtel qui se
trouvait sur le rive gauche pourquoi pas
mais au même enfin beaucoup de conflits
internes pendant que je prenais
l'ascenseur et que le type odes quand
même a dit euh le même chambre que
d'habitude monsieur
gbour oh là quel horreur alors on est
monté dans
le c'était pas mal comme ça et puis
quand on arrivait dans la chambre j'ai
tout de même demandé si je pouvais aller
trouver les salles de bain et quand je
suis sortie c'était peut-être 6h du
matin il dormait je trouvais ça
tellement joli ça me donnait le temps de
filer au drugstore d'acheter un petit
disque en 45 tours qui était yum yum
yumy love my et de le mettre entre ses
doigts de pied ou et de partir intact
donc belle histoire c'était trop mignon
oui trop mignon alors pour pour Jane
Serge ginbour écrira deux concepts album
magnifiques qui sont melodyie Nelson et
l'homme à la tête de chou qui sont
inspirés inspirés par Jane ouais mais
d'abord il y a cette fameuse chanson qui
avait été écrite pour Brigitte Bardot
enregistré par Brigitte bardau et donc
Gunter Zac son milliardaire de Marie
avait refusé la sorti je t'aime moi non
plus alors il y a jamais eu de clip de
cette chanson il y a il y a jamais eu de
télévision on a un document super H qui
nous a été prêté par vous et nous vous
en remercions Jane voici je t'aime moi
non
[Musique]
plus je
t'aime je t'aime
oui je
t'aime moi non
[Musique]
plus oh mon
amour comme la
vague
irrésolu je vais je vais et je
viens entre tes
reins je dè et je viens
entre
tesines et je me re
tien je t'aime je
t'aime oui je
t'aime oh mon
amour tu es la
B moi l'île nue
tu VO tu VO tout viens
entre mes Rin
tu viens
entre mes reins et je te re
joie je
t'aime je t'aime oh oui je
t'ime moi non
plus voilà GB et je t'aime moi non plus
vous avez du mal à vous avez du mal à à
regarder ces images non je regarde pas
ouais vous regardez pas ou en même temps
on pe vous dire une chose j c'est que
vous a eu beaucoup de chance que votre
amour avec Serge soit immortalisé d'une
façon aussi aussi magnifique c'est pas
toutes les femmes qui ont ça non non
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec ça ça n'a
rien à voir avec les gratitude c'est
c'est déjà très bizarre quand quand
quelqu'un où on Nimagine pas le
non-existence
euh parle dans le taxi ouais donc on
demande au taximan de changer de de
chaîne après ça vous essayez d'éviter
des images sur la télévision pas parce
que ça vous fait pas plaisir mais parce
que ça
fait une chose bizarre de voir bouger
quelqu'un qui ne bougera plus c'est
aussi simple que ça alors quand c'est
les papa maman normale c'est pas sur
tous les télévisions de tout le temps
que tu es confronté à ça enfin avec le
temps ça passera sans doute ouais al
cette chans une chanson c'est une
chanson qui fait le tour du monde ça
fait un scandale d'abord ça fait un
scandale qui se vend qui se vend à des
millions d'exemplaires qui fait un
scandale évidemment quelques mois après
la sortie du disque tout à coup il y a
le Vatican le Vatican qui désigne du
doigt Jane et Serge comme étant le
couple à scandale non et oui il a
toujours dit que le pape était son
meilleur attaché de presse ou oui non
mais c'est vrai le BBC l'avait bann
aussi on a grimpé dans le chart mais le
BBC stoïquement a refusé de jouer notre
version et qui a joué une version
orchestrale de jet mon su qui du sucès
oui alors que la version originale
chantée par Serge et par Jane était
numéro 1 des h PARAD anglais c'est
d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui la seule
chanson de ginsbourg qui est vraiment
connue dans le monde entier et vous Jane
à jamais vous êtes Jane je t'aime
bkin mais c'est oui parce que mais c'est
assez joli parce que autant que parfois
votre passé constamment sur un passé ça
peut être irritant mais l'autre chose
j'ai pris un taximan anglais et puis il
a dit qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la
vie ou un truc comme ça comme d'habitude
et au lieu de mentir comme souvent
disons que je travailler pour je sais
pas un un compagé
obscur j'ai j'ai dit en fait j'ai chanté
un chanson dans le temps mais vous en
souvenez sans doute pas et j'ai dit
c'éta une chanson français
avec S gbour et ça s'appelait je t'aime
moi non plus il a freiné son taxi de
tout de vite il dit je t il a dit sege
gesburg il a dit moi j'ai eu trois
enfants sur cette sur cette disque là il
a dit c'est génial
alors après je me suis dit il y a pas
beaucoup de monde quand même là où tu
vas que tu as tout d'un coup les taximan
qui se freine et qui t'invite chez lui
pour montrer la sa copie qu'il avait
encore gardé trois brillantes enfants
qui ont maintenant je sais pas 30 ans 25
je disais tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
les les les rappeurs font beaucoup de de
sample de de ginsbourg et puis même même
pas les rappeurs d'ailleurs parce que le
groupe
Texas groupe de rock dans son dernier
album à SL je t'aime moi non plus et ça
s'appelle guitar Song et c'est Charline
spitery et
[Musique]
Texas
beautiful in all the Strang
places you feel
good your sweet
t the WEA is changing as I look at your
[Musique]
face
to the
[Musique]
FL you know
we Haven had a dream in such a long time
now it's raining here and theaves are on
the ground I'm seping warm outside it's
cold
and that's my guitar and I will play for
you all day
[Musique]
so
many in my
mind may I Dr so
[Musique]
much but out
the
found to the
FL you know
we Haven had a dream in such a long time
now it's r here
and on
the warm outs
cold that's my guitar and I will play
for all day Haven had a dream in such a
long time
now it's raining here and the on the
ground but I'm warm outside
coldway that's my guitar and I will play
for you all
day
be all
[Musique]
right if you St
tonighten Dream such a long time
now it's raining here
and on
the but
i'mep
that's my guitar and I will play for you
all Haven had a dream such a long time
now it's raining here
and on
the I'm warm outs is cold
and my guitar and I will play for you
all day
[Musique]
je t'aime moi non plus version 2001
c'est le group Texas et ça s'appelle
guitare song alors Serge avec avec cette
chanson à prouvé qu'il pvait vraiment
réussir mais mondialement là c'est
carrément un tube planétaire il a 43 ans
il veut créer une œuvre un peu plus
ambitieuse une œuvre
d'avant-gardeavantgarde parce il faut
savoir que dans dans la bouche de son
père Joseph Ginsburg qui vit qui vit
encore en 70 71 il n'y a pas de plus
beau compliment que le mot avant-garde
et donc après avoir montré qu'il pouvait
faire des chansons commerciales après
avoir démontré qu'il pouvait vendre des
millions de carour à travers le monde
ginsbourg veut se lancer dans une œuvre
plus ambitieuse c'est l'album Histoire
de Melody
directement inspiré par Jan le père de
ginsbourg meurt quelques temps après
mais juste avant il écoute Histoire de
Melody Nelson et il dit Lucien a composé
un chefdœuvre une œuvre d'avant-garde
mellody Nelson voilà donc Melody Nelson
et l'homme à la tête de chou ce sont des
concepts album c'est vrai qu'en
Angleterre il y a beaucoup de concept
album il y a eu sir John Pepper qui
était sans doute le premier donc il s
colle avec Jean-Claude Vanier un
orchestre symphonique une Coral c'est
l'histoire d'un homme qui est rendu fou
d'amour par une petite Anglaise qui le
renverse avec sa Rolls il a retourné sa
veste elle était doubl de vison il la
retournera à nouveau mais cette fois
elle sera doublé de lapin
Magnetto ainsi je déconnais avant que je
ne perde le contrôle de la Rolls
j'avançais lentement ma voiture
driva et un he violent me tira soudain
de ma
rverie
merde 'appelle
com
m Melody
[Musique]
C Melody Nelson Melody Nelson c'est une
petite fille
d'aujourd'hui c'est une petite
Rouine avec des taches de
rousseur pas sublimement belle mais
jolie non elle est belle
elle est belle est-ce qu'elle me
ressemble un peu de ça ah oui et-tu
hleuse de
[Musique]
moi un peu comme pig Malon VO c'est tout
pourquoi tu me fais mourir je te fais
mourir afin que notre amour soit
éternel
ah
mélodie tu m'en auras fait
faire des
conneries
[Musique]
Adada sur mon
dos
oh
mélodie l'amour tu ne sais pas ce que
[Musique]
c'est
tu me l'as
dit mais tout ce que tu dis estil vrai
voilà Mélody
Nelson
alors contrairement contrairement à son
habitude Serge qui d'habitude faisait
des chansons comme ça dans une nuit là
il passe beaucoup de temps non à Londres
avec vous d'ailleurs pour faire cet
album non on croyait que ça serait mais
tubesque je croyait que ça sidérerait
tout le monde et en fait il faut savoir
tout de même que que Serge et moi
d'ailleurs on était pas des vendeurs
comme disait s on était très aimés les
les radios nous chuchotaient on était on
était joujoté par tout le monde parce
que ils aimaient bien notre présence
mais on était pas les vendeurs et on n
pas vendu une disque d'or ni lui ni moi
sur rien incro dou ni ni mélodie ni
l'homme la tête de chou ça bien vendu
mais c'est la première fois je pense
qu'il a eu un un disque d'or c'était
avec des rastar et moi la première fois
que j'ai eu un disque d'or c'était
c'était avec euh babyalone et Babylone
mais tout cette époque là c'était très
suivi les carpentiers nous a fait des ch
mais délicieux donc tout le monde savait
qui on était mais on vendait pas mais a
dit pas grave oui à prop pour des autres
personnes aucune amertume vis-à-vis des
personnes qui vendaient des qui
cartonnaient sec parce que quelque part
peut-être il savaient que ça durera
c'est éternel on en parle 30 ans après
on na pas fini d'en parler ce qu'on
lisait dans la presse à l'époque c'était
à propos de Melody Nelson c'était le
premier poème symphonique de l'ASH pop
on lit des choses magnifiques il y a
Isabelle adan qui qui qui m'a dit à
propos de Melody Nelson c'était de la
littérature
musicale elle se plongeait làdedans elle
était adolescente elle adorait ça
littérature musicale c'est magnifique
bien alors on va écouter une autre une
autre chanson de l'album Melody Nelson
par le plus ginsbourien des auteurs
compositeurs interprèt d'aujourd'hui
c'est
[Musique]
Miek ça c'est l'histoire de de mellodyie
Nelson
qu'à part moi-même
personne n'a jamais pris dans ses bras
ça vous
étonne mais c'est comme ça
elle on avait de l'amour
pauvre mélodie Nelson
ouais mais elle en avait des
tonnes mais ses jours étaient
comptés 14
automn et 15
[Musique]
été petit animal que cette
mélodie
Nelson une adorable
garçonne
et si délicieux
enfant que je
déconne qu'un
[Musique]
instant
oh ma mélodie ma mélodie
Nelson aimable petite
conne tu étais la
condition si école
d'Ana de ma raison
[Musique]
oui alors je disais que en présentant
mieus qu'il était le plus ginsbourien
des auteurs compositeurs interprète
actuel je crois que vous venez de le
démontrer euh c'est formidable vous
connaissez tous les deux il a fait les
avalanches pour vous non dans votre
dernier album oui oui oui moi je le oui
moi je le trouve très attractif et en
plus il rougit pour du vrai il a rien de
plus joli il rougit parce qu'il est pas
trop dans le showbs il a gardé une
certaine pureté vous méfiez beaucoup du
du show business pourquoi avez-vous
choisi cette chanson euh ben pour moi
c'est la meilleure c'est la plus chante
ouais elle est magnifique une bonne
raison ou c'est magnifique vraiment je
veux dire vous avez donner le frisson en
la en la chantant alors Jane bah à cette
époque là vous devenez avec Serge un peu
le le couple des années 70 vous faites
la Une des magazines alors c'est vrai
que c'est très un couple assez pas
choquant enfin c'est sulfureux il a 43
ans vous en avez 22 il est fier de se
montrer avec vous en plus ouis on
rigolait bien oui ouis on rentit avec
des poubelles non c'était c'était
vraiment très gay parce que comme il y
avait plein de différents boîtes comme
c'est tout était oui il était en plus
quelqu'un de terriblement curieux et de
de TER
sensuel quand même je veux dire vraiment
vraiment sensuel alors ça fait que oui
c'était une nuit nocturne extrêmement
intéressante et puis on finissait
toujours dans un endroit qui s'appelait
le calavados
ou oh là là et puis après ça on
repartait vers Pigal où les [__]
étaient gentils avec moi parce que il
voulaient pas que je prendre trop leur
patch mais mais quand il comprenaient
que je cherchais pas la même cllientè
ouais partait dans les hôtels par là et
puis on prenait des croissants on
redescendait puis on rentrait rue de
Verneuil et et on entendait les enfant
se réveillaient et nous on on était
trembballé avec des oui avec des
poubelles et puis après ça les enfants
parai à l'école et nous on parti se
coucher jusqu'au 2h de l'après-midi tous
les jours je pense jolie vie très jolie
vie alors vous étiez s'amuse vous dez
son son interprète alors je vous dis au
revoir mais sa que je dis à bientôt et
puis on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
mélancoliabus j'ai je ne sais quoi d'un
garçon
manquer
les autres filles on de
bonichant et moi moi je tre aussi PL
qu'un
garç John toi qui pres tes baskets et
tes yeux
candides dans les nom les lieux
Sid John J les décharges publ sont Les
Atlantides que survolle les mouches
quand Johny tous les
camions
VI bien
[Musique]
despant baby
doll come tu dans bien le rock and
[Musique]
roll né
fol que son dévenu toutes tes idoles
voilà jberkin chante Serge gbourg je
crois que il y a rarement eu une telle
osmose dans un couple c'est-à-dire à la
fois sur le plan affectif bien sûr mais
aussi sur le plan artistique quoi c'est
je crois que j'ai j'ai eu vraiment une
chance incroyable pas seulement les les
12 ans que j'étais avec Serge mais par
la suite jusqu'au j jusqu' le le jour
qu'il soit mort que d'être sa confidente
ça c'est peut-être les chose le plus
rare avec les couples même si on a raté
son vie de couple soi-disant que l'autre
garde un chambre symbolique dans la
maison de l'autre même quand il y a
d'autres personnes bambou ou que dans
mon cas à moi il y a eu loup SGE s'est
placé quand même en disons qu'il était
papa deux il était parrain de loup il a
eu cette élégance extrême de jamais m'av
avoir lapidé en public d'avoir toujours
dit que le fautif c'était lui d'être
vraiment un élégance suprême et plus
après ça il m'avait écrit je sais pas
très bien compé mais 13 titres sur
babyon Babylon encore lost song encore
12 encore sur le derniè qu'il a fait
peut-être 6 mois avant de mourir c'était
tout de même amour desfes donc ça
fait enfin ça fait le compte de je ne
sais pas avec avec F le bonheur des de
Soushi les chansons les plus magnifiques
du répertoire français alors il m'a
confié peut-être son face B quand
j'étais parti ça je le crois réellement
que sa face féminin aussi et il y en
avait une face très féminin de SGE et et
et C oui c'est dans tous les cas il a
été Dandi dans la vie mais il était
aussi Dandi dans la tête c'est ce qu'on
peut dire quand vous nous racontez cette
cette élégance il y a aussi quelque
chose de de très particulier c'est que
quand Serge a fait chanter Jane dans la
presse on disait mais Jane n'est pas une
chanteuse c'est une murmureuse c'est une
murmurante en fait il avait une
technique il a demandé à tous les filles
qui lui chantaient parce qu'en fait il
était beaucoup plus intéressé de faire
chanter des actrices mignonnes comme Mar
comme
bardau chanter je t'aime moi non plus
d'ailleurs oui oui je sais c'est pour ça
que je l'ai chanté vite fait pour que il
se trouve pas dans une cabine
téléphonique avec cette bombe sexuelle
non non évidemment j'ai fait ça par pure
jalousie et puis le tout toutes les
personnes Anna cararina et cetera le
tenter plus que des vraies chanteuses à
voir comme il disaitou alors Étienne
vous êtes fan de de Jane et de tout ce
qu'elle a fait avec Serge j'imagine que
vous êtes fan de Serge aussi oui bien
sûr ça vous a inspiré vous j'imagine
cette façon de chanter non mais je sais
c'est sexy moi je très très présent et
très sexy la radio ça passe bien parce
que la radio c'est su inal quoi ça passe
vraiment tranquillement dans l'oreille
bien alors vous allez nous chanter mon
amour baisé tous les deux en duo en duo
pourquoi cette chanson parce que c'est
la face un petit peu un petit peu qu'on
a mis un petit peu de côté le côté
justement sexy le côté pétillant le côté
un peu léger et moi j'aime bien ce ce ce
côté-là et je trouve que c'est un album
génial c'est extrait du premier album de
Jane s'appelle diduda qui est qui est un
chef-dœuvre au niveau des arrangements
et des compositions vraiment c'est un
album référence enfin en tout cas pour
moi donc pouvoir le chanter aujourd'hui
avec Jane c'est
bah allez-y mes enfants au boulot hein
voilà j Berkin et Tieno mon amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
baisé oh mon amour mon amour
baisé baisé d'amour baisé tendre baisé
chou oh mon amour mon amour
baiser baiser mouillé baiser chaud
baiser fou oh mon amour mon amour
baiser baisz brûant baisz l' gros bisous
bais Doig
[Musique]
poucesoucheig
P mon amour mon amour
baisé baisé d'amour baisé tendre baisé
fou oh mon amour mon amour
baisé baiser mouillé bais chaud gros
bisous baiser cou baiser gorge baiser
sein bais ventre baiser reins baiser
hanches baiser cuisses bais
tout oh mon amour mon amour
baisé baisé d'amour baisé tendre baisé
fou oh mon amour mon amour
baisé baisz mouillé baisz chaud baisz
dou oh mon amour mon amour
baisé baiser brûlant baisé lour gros
bisous baise Doig sur S pousces et puis
BZ bouche baisez doigts su pouces puis
baisez V mon amour mon amour
baisé baisé d'amour baisé tendre baisé
fou oh mon amour mon amour
baisé baisé mouillé baisé chouud gros
bisous baisé cou baisé gorge baisé F
baisé
baisz ventre bais hanches baisz cuisses
baisz
[Musique]
tout j Birkin et tien Dao mon amour
maisisé formidable tous les deux là
alors Jame c'est l'époque où on appelle
Serge ginzebourg un peu monsieur Birkin
parce que lui bon jamais jamais alors ça
c'est encore une délicatesse de sa part
parce que jamais jamais jamais on
l'appelait monsieur ber mais à l'époque
j ce qui se passe à l'époque je lui il
fait des albums magnifiques mais enfin
qui se vendent quand même pas très bien
et vous vous devenez parallèlement la
petite fiancée des Français c'est-à-dire
que vous devenez quand même une star
nationale pendant que lui fait des
albums un peu un peu compliqués d'abord
vous faites la piscine avec film de
Jacques day avec Alain Delon Maurice
reney gros succès et je dis il était
mignon parce qu'il avait tellement peur
de Deon qu'il arrivait avec une vaste
automobile à pé mais trop grand pour les
petites rues et au-dessus de
l'automobile on avait attaché un
automobile extraordinairement chic comme
vous pouvez imaginer un Cadelac je pense
même que c'était et on avait attaché sur
le toit des couches de quê des des
prapteurs des des peau de bébé et cetera
enfin c'était arrivé comme une caravane
de il v vous voir il veneit voir donc
sur le tournage de de la piscine à Saint
tropé quand même il se mfiit de long
quand même
oui à tort non non non après ça j'avais
une immense chance d'être prise pour le
et puis les films de Zid ou voilà vous
Denez voilà vous devenez c'est pour ça
bien sûr vous devenez pas plus célèbre
que lui mais très célèbre il y a la
moutarde me montonné par exemple c'est
pas un film qui restera dans les journal
du cinéma français ENF c'est un film qui
vous a rendu quoi queon sait pas qui
vous a rendu extrêmement populaire en
toutous les cas il y a comment réussir
quand on est con et pleurnichard vous en
souvenez cela pas oublié
celui-là il vit comment ginsbourg votre
succès ça il en prend embrage ou jamais
il avait l'air toujours d'être ravi ma
mère m'a dit que j'avais une chance fou
parce queelle vivait avec avec mon père
qui était jaloux comme tout et qu' avait
embarqué à la campagne juste trop trop
loin pour pouvoir jouer au théâtre alors
que ça j'avais l'air d'être ravi de mon
succès parce que mon succès était son
succès il il était pour mon sucè fariqué
oui bien sûr oui alors il était content
il voulait toute cette histoire de
presse finalement parce qu' on se
vautrait sur les pelouses avec des
enfants quand même on était pas non plus
les les couples très cachés ça fait que
il trouvait tout ça joli parce que si on
était dans les journaux ça veut dire que
les gens nous aimaient bien et il avait
un terreur de pasêre dans le prê voulait
être aimé oui oui parce qu'un couvrante
Jeanette il m'a dit si une couvrante est
une couvrante même si ça disait du mal
donc il il était il était absolument
tellement insucure dans le fond
tellement insucure que ça le rassurait
que les gens nous enchînement parce que
là on en arrive à cette à ce concept
album 3è concept album rocker and the
bunker ce ve dire quand même on rock
autour du BU cœur il évoque sa judéité à
contrario bien sûr mais enfin pour la
première fois il évoque dans oui il fait
un album très très provoque qui sort en
75 qui s'appelle rock de bunker sur
lequel il y a une chanson qui s'appelait
nazck d'ailleurs il aurait pu appeler
l'album nazck et sur cet album il n
question que de que de ses souvenirs de
la guerre de quand il portait l'é toile
de Chérif comme il disait comme il
disait si bien ou alors on regarde c'est
naziroc Serge
gbourilez vos B noir les garsustez bien
vous accroch B P vos cors allez venez ça
va seer on va
danser on va danser
[Musique]
le maquillez vos lèvres les gars avec
des rouges délicats vous desbouch
sanglant noirou si ça vous tente on va
dans
[Musique]
de on va
[Applaudissements]
dans voilà Serge ginbour rock around the
bunker le morceau s'appelle
nazick alors nous a rejoint Jacky
bonsoir alorsons vous êtes animateur sur
TFJ c'est ça oui je fais le Rabbi Jacky
ch le Raby jaqu avant il y a eu doroté
mais ce que peu de gens savent c'est
qu'avant vous avez été l'attaché de
presse de Serge G che chez Philips oui
de 73 à 80 alors ça se passait comment
par exemple la sortie d'un disque comme
ça qui est extrêmement just ah oui oui
ben justement je men suis occupé de rock
bunker j'étais jeté de partout et à
l'époque il y avait que trois radios
donc je me suis fait jeter des trois
radios c'està-dire Europe 1 RTL et
France Inter et c'était fini et c'était
fini ou de partout alors à cette époque
là ginsbourg a sa première crise
cardiaque non c'est là où il a beaucoup
bu il a beaucoup fumé il se droguaent
pas tellement gbour non il se il se
droguaent pas du tout pas du tout jamais
drogué
la crise cardiaque c'est d uniquement à
l'alcool la cigarette uniquement ça
alors est-ce que vous avez été témoin de
cette histoire que que François raconé
là d'abord oui quand Serge a à sa crise
cardiaque il est en train d'enregistrer
je suis venu te dire que je m'en vais
euh et puis donc il est hospitalisé et
il est tellement déprimé que la presse
ne soit pas au courant qu'il est à
l'hôpital qu'il appelle lui-même les
journaliste oui souv ça oui moi je me
souviens très bien oui oui mais moi je
me souviens quand on avait caché ça
tellement bien
parce que il était à l'hôpital américain
et moi je rentrais par derrière dans le
je je rencontrais d'ailleurs Henry
comatias qui lui avait sa femme à cœur
ouvert donc tous les deux on était
extrêmement précautionneux fait gaffe à
la presse et cetera et puis un jour je
suis arrivée dans dans No chambre de
serège et puis il a vu tu as vu j'ai le
premiè de françoir je dis les salot
comment ils ont pu et cetera et oui
Jésus oui c'est lui qui avait appelé il
avait appelé une COP un copine une
journaliste à lui qu'il aimait beaucoup
et qui a fait le coupvrant parce qu'il a
dit tu comprends je suis en train de
crever les Français savent pas donc
c'était c'était ça il adorait les médias
quoi c'était bien de travailler avec lui
parce qu'il voulait tout faire il
refusait rien toutes la presse toutes
les radios toutes les T souenez moi je
me souviens les premières interviews que
il y a 25 ans Serge avait été le premier
à accepter descendre de police dans
Rocket folk bien alors après il y a 20
personnes qui ont accepté mais le
premier c'était Serge il avait dit tout
de suite oui il nous connaissait pas du
tout faire tris rouers partoutou il
était très mais comme il était seul est
triste ça l'amusé vous l'avez rencontré
ginsbourg Étienne justement quand quand
j'ai enregistré chez les y il a demandé
à François hardardi de m'appeler je
viens le voir et à ce moment-là j'ai
commencé à avoir une relation avec Lui
régulière et donc on s'est vu on s'est
vu assez assz souvent ouaisou CIT
vraiment des après-midis luxueuses quoi
parce que vraiment rue de Verneuil parce
qu'il y avait pas de travail à la clé il
y avait rien pour le plaisir pour le
plaisir alors à à cette époque Serge
ginbourg écrit comme vous l'avez av dit
je suis venu te dire que je m'en vais
alors au départ évidemment c'est une
chanson sur une rupture amoureuse et
puis compte tenu des des circonstances
sanitaires de Serge de son
hospitalisation à l'Hôpital Américain ça
prend un tout autre sens on va voir
cette chanson chantée par Jean-Louis
Aubert mais avant je voudrais B vous
remercier Jane et Étienne d'avoir été
avec nous Jan on vous retrouve à la fin
de l'émission parce que vous êtes la
marine de la soirée et merci Étienne à
bientôt voici Jean-Louis Aubert je suis
venu te dire que je
m'en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis venu te dire que je m'en
[Musique]
vais tes larmes ne pourront rien
changer comme dis bien versline au vent
mauvais je suis venu te dire je
[Musique]
m'envis tu te souviens des jours anciens
et tu
pleures tu suffoques tu bémis à présent
qu' sonner uneheure des adieu à
jamais je suis au
regret de te dire que je m'en vais
je t'aimais oui mais je suis venu te
dire que je m'en
vais les sanglons n pourront rien
[Musique]
changer comme si bien versline au vent
mauvais je suis venu te dire que je m'en
vais
tu te souviens des jours heureux et tu
pleures tu sens tu géis à présent qu'à
fit l'URE des adieux à jamais
oui je suis au
regret de te dire que je
m'enville tu m'en as trop fait je suis
venu te dire
que je m'en
bais tes larmes ne pourront rien
changer comme d'ici bien vers l'INE au
vent
mauvais je suis venu te dire que je m'en
vais tu te souviens des jours anciens et
tu pleures
tu slot tu blém à présent
[Musique]
C des adieux à
jamaisou je suis au
regret de te dire que je m'en
vais je t'aime oui mais je suis venu te
dire que je m'en
vais
des sangles long n'y pourront rien
changer comme ici bien ver l'INE ou vant
mauvais je suis venu te dire que je
[Musique]
m'enveille tu te souviens des jours
anciens et tu
pleur tu sanglotes tu gémis à présent
cassonne la des adieux à
jamais oui je suis au
regret de te dire que je t'aimais
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
Jean-Louis
Aubert je suis venu te dire que je m'en
vais chanson préférée de
ginbourg c'est difficile c'est comme les
Beatles tellement ou mais j'aime bien
j'aime bien les chansons de rupture
comme ça et puis je trouve qu'elle elle
a bien sa
pudeur j'aime beaucoup la mélodie aussi
c'est une chanson qu'on a beaucoup
écouté beaucoup entendu quand ginbourg
est mort en 91id tout le monde la rejoué
en lui redonnant ce sens que la crise
cardiaque lui avait donné c'estàd audelà
de la une chanson sur une rupture
amoureuse vous étiez ami vous étiez
copains avec ginsbourg j'étais le petit
gars ouais j'étais son petit gars ouais
il aimait bien le contact des plus
jeunes il a écrit plus tard pour bijou
star shooter avait repris le le point
sonneur des Lilas et avec téléphone il a
jamais eu des des véléités de de
composition de la part de Serge pour
vous euh non je me souviens pas de ça
mais par contre je crois qu'il a essayé
de m'éduquer un peu un peu musicalement
peut-être un peu en littérature aussi
mais et il faisait il me fait beaucoup
alors il aimait bien me faire Stravinski
donc il mettait l'oiseau de feu et il se
mettait sur le canapé chez lui et il me
faisait pendant 3 heur le chef
d'orchestre en me montrant toutes les
parties musical pour m'ouvrir les
oreilles on arrive à l'homme à la tête
de chou al racontez-nous le le pitch de
l'homme à la tête de chou l'histoire
l'homme à la tête de chou donc c'est un
autre concept album qu'il sort dans les
années 70 il le sort en tout début 70 7
en fait on est en pleine période punk
c'est vrai qu'on écoute les sex pistol
on écoute les Clash à l'époque et
ginsbourg il réussi à être punk non pas
dans la forme parce qu'il se met pas à
chanter comme un énervé avec des accords
à à 120 à l'URE pas du tout mais dans le
fond parce que c'est un album qui est
très nilist qui est très destroy et qui
raconte l'histoire d'un homme rendu fou
d'amour par une champouineuse dont il
découvre évidemment s'en fout d'amour
pour don il découvre un Beaujour que
cette champouineuse a deux amants et que
il la surprend dans un lit et qu'elle
ressemble à une guitare à de Jack donc
je vous laisse deviner et donc
évidemment ça le rend complètement
cinglé il termine à l'asile et il
devient l'homme à tête de chou l'homme à
tête de chou
chef-dœuvre et puis des Vendes derrière
qui sont000 exempla c'est ça 18000
exemplaires tu tu té mooins Jacky et et
alors pour se rattraper quelques mois
plus tard il se dit tiens il y a un truc
sympa ça le fait marrer c'est le rythme
disco il trouve ça sympa 78 c'est
l'année des bidgies tout ça et il se dit
tiens je vais torcher une ch ch en 3
minutes est-ce que je pe même pas 3
minutes he g oui est-ce
que est-ce que je suis généreux g ouais
c'est ça est-ce que je peux torcher une
chanson en 3 minutes oui il y arrive
très bien et il fait 6enson et là et là
et là j'arrive en radio à Europe 1 à RTL
à Inter et là les programmateurs me dit
Jacky c'est génial on va le passer c'est
le tube de l'été et ça a été le tube de
l'été d'ailleurs parce que ça a vendu
avec une chanson que ginsbourg détesta
oui oui parceil en avait un peu honte il
en avait un peu honte parce qu'il
m'appelait quand même parce qu'il était
relativement angoissé il m'appelait tous
les jours alors tu as vu un tel tu as vu
programmateur je dis oui il va le passer
ah bon tu crois mais c'est une grosse
merde ouais ouais mais c'est pas grave
il était quand même content d'en vendre
mais il avait un peu honte quoi ouais
gazbourg si
[Applaudissements]
sexon
sex le
soleil aux
[Musique]
élites sur exite
des petits seins de paqu
Lite qui
[Musique]
s'agite toi petite c'est sûr que tu es
un
[Musique]
Hite
voilà sex
and bien mais je vous remercie en tous
les cas tous les deux d'avoir été avec
nous on termine ce tableau hein parce
que là gbour est au plus mal de nouveau
c'estd il y a des rebondissements dans
l'histoire là il est de nouveau plus mal
comme à la fin des années 50 et
heureusement il va être sauvé par le
réget voici les années
[Applaudissements]
rég
voilà donc vous êtes sur France 2
première partie de soirée ginbourg
auteur compositeur interprète 2uxème
partie de soirée les autres ginsbourg
c'est-à-dire évidemment l'écrivain le
peintre le réalisateur l'acteur le Night
cluber le séducteur et 3è partie de
soirée ginsbourg sur scène voilà on est
au tableau 4 les années régé 1978 19 81
alors pourquoi le régaet pourquoi
ginsbourg d'un seul coup passe de
l'homme à la tête de chou au réget euh
c'est le rythme qui l'intéresse
c'estàdire que c'est vrai que dans la
deuxiè moitié des années 70 on commence
à écouter beaucoup Bob Marley pet t toch
et cetera et ginsbor est intrigué par ce
rythme qui vient de Kingston et qui
vient de la Jamaïque et il se dit que
lui qui pratique déjà le toover
c'està-dire il au lieu de chanter il
parle sur c'est ça il se dit que sa
proseodie collerait bien au rythme régué
et donc il il prend la décision avec
Philippe lorichum qui est son directeur
artistique de partir à Kingston et là il
enregistre avec les musiciens de Peter
toch et avec les coristes de Bob Marley
en 5 jours il enregistre aux armes et
cetera son premier album reggaé sur
lequel il y a la fameuse marseillaise
regg comme d'habitude tout commence par
un scandale ginsbourg reprend l'hymne
national la Marseillaise au armes et
cetera ce soir c'est quelqu'un par qui
le scandale est arrivé aussi lorsqu'il
interpréta 12 Fran de Charles traet avec
son groupe carte de séjour c'est Rachid
qui n la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chante allons enfants de la
Patrie le jour de gloire est
arrivé contre nous la tyrannie les tards
sanglant
[Musique]
élevés
rournez-vous dans les
campagnes
sold VI
[Musique]
J
fils
[Musique]
et
et l'amour sacré de la
patrie conduit soutienv
Vengeurs liberté liberté chérie combat
avec des défenseurs aux armes aux armes
et
cetera aux armes et
cetera
[Musique]
et nous entrerons dans la carrière quand
tousous aînés n seront plus nous y
trouverons leur poussière et la trace de
leur
ouais et
Cera et
CER
et
[Musique]
C
duons
patri est
arriv
et C
et merci
bienvenue ch aux armes et cetera quand
quand vous avez fait 12 Fran à l'époque
de carte de séjour ça avz fait autant de
bruit que quand ginbourg avait fait c
c'est marrant parce que la première fois
que j'ai fait une télé avec 12 franc
cétait il y avait gbour à côté de moi ce
jourl ouais ouais donc c'était une
émission de télé O accepé à cette époque
là qu'on pouvait chanter des chansons
comme ça moi ce qui m'intéresse che
gbourg c'est son côté politique mine de
rien mine de rien ouais il était très
engagé quand même ouais hein alors cette
chanson a fait un scandale mais mais
grave c'està-dire que là vous allez nous
lire un passage
de mich qui sort qui 42 là ouais qui
sort en juin 79 et il s'élève évidemment
avec véhémence contre ginsbourg qui a
osé s'en prendre à l'hymne national
alors il dit ceci quand je vois
apparaître Serge ginzbourg je me sens
devenir écologique euh comprenez par là
que je me trouve aussitôt en état de
défense contre une sorte de pollution
ambiante hein qui me semble émaner
spontanément de sa personne et de son
œuvre comme de certains tuyaux
d'échappement sous un tunnel routier
c'est quand même monstrueusement hein et
puis alors il dit pire il y a pire il
n'est évidemment pas un homme de bonne
foi qui songerait à associer cette
parodie scandaleuse de notre hymne
national et le judaïsme de ginsbourg
mais ce ne sont pas précisément les
hommes de bonne foi qui constituent les
bataillons de l'antisémitisme était-ce
donc bien le moment de fournir à ceux-ci
une méchante occasion de faire bon
marché de tous les Juifs de France
est-ce que c'est pas abominable je crois
qu'il était assez peiné parce que tout
de même quand quelqu'un refaire de vous
comme si vous étiez un gaz nuisible et
euh d' d'un pléchappement dans un tunnel
ça vous fait assez assez bizarre
peut-être d' tant hailli à ce point et
puis ils avaient quand même pris le soin
d'illustrer le magazine avec un photo de
seège assez atypique d'ailleurs avec une
bouteille de bière à à la à la bouche et
bien montrer son son nez crochu en fait
pour la première fois SGE balancé euh au
lieu d'être sur les pages sur les pages
culturelles il était sur les pages
sociales et là tout d'un coup je pense
que ça le ravissait du coup parce que il
a il avait j'étais j'étais comme là la
nuit avec Philippe lerichum quand nous
sommes arrivés à Strasbourg c'est j'éta
avec S rasta et comme il a dit ils ont
assez d' merde chez eux je veux pas
qu'il meure pour nous ou pour lui plutôt
parce que on a eu des alertes à la bombe
parce que il y avait un groupe assez
assez méchant qu' faut dire
effectivement c'est que le scandale ne
s'arrête pas à Michel Droit évidemment
il y a ce concert de Strasbourg avec les
parachutistes les rastas Serge comme
vous venez de le dire leur demande de ne
pas rester sur scène le concert est
annulé il a fait mieux parce que dans la
nu
ils ont eu deux alertes à la bombe et
puis on savait très bien qu'ils
attendaient dans la salle il y avait un
rangé de paratroouopeur et c'est là où
tout d'un coup on est fier d'être
témoins de la secondde qui change un
homme en héros parce que c'était annulé
le concert on aurait dû partir ailleurs
et de le bus sur sur JC sège suivi par
féip le richum et moi il il est monté
sur scène on est derrière des baffes et
il a pris le micro par ça l'éner pour
tous ces fans qui étai là que à cause de
quelques quelques personnes oui que que
que que que le concert soit annulé donc
il a arraché ce micro et deune voix
blanche il a chanté le le le le le
première version enfin la version
intégrale de la marsise donc les
parachuteurs dans les premiers un ou de
R ne savaient plus quoi faire il mett
debout il s'assayent il enlevent leur
Berret ils avent ils avent faire un
parce qu'évidment c'était l'hyne
national et après ça il est parti en
faisant ça comme ça à à à à eux et
c'était à ce moment-là que voilà qu' il
s'est viré en héros il a fait là où
d'autres n'ont pas fait il a fait
courage acte de courage extraordinaire
on va voir ça on va voir le jour où il
allit allumer ses clopes sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu à l'Arc de Triomphe et
puis alors ironie du sort il achète le
manuscrit de rouget de lî à versaill
dans une vente aux enchères on va voir
tout ça d'abord je voulais remercier
Rachid d'avoir ét avec nous je voulais
vous dire vous êtes formidablebles tous
là ce soir vous êtes ça fait très
plaisir de vous voir réuni pour chanter
Serge ginsbourg merci rachita merci Rach
voilà Serge ginbourg la suite du
scandale de la Marseillaise Magneto
Jérôme je suis un
insoumis et qui est redonné à la
Marseillaise son sens
[Musique]
initial et je vous demanderai de la
chanter avec moi allons enfants de la
patrie le jour de gloire est
arrivé contre nous de la
tyrannie
[Musique]
les je pense que le régé c'est une
musique révolutionnaire la
Marseillaise une un champ
révolutionnaire bon cond dessus on danse
on dansait bien sû un carmagol on
dansera sur un marseillaise
entendez-vous dans les campagnes mugir C
féroces soldat ils viennent jusque dans
nos bras et gorger nos fils nos
[Musique]
compagnes ce manuscrit est écrit
entièrement et signé par rouget de lîle
5000 50000 52000 120000 125000 130000
135000 135000 personne personne auond
135000 voilà donc la suite du scandale
de la
Marseillaise et puis l'achat par Serge
ginbourg du manuscrit original de rouet
de Lille où il a d'ailleurs écit aux
armes et cetera hein absolument parce
que roug Lille oui c'est ça il voulait
pas se taper tout le refrein il écrivait
aux armes finalement c'était raccord
j'ai dis à Michel Dr qui n'est plus là
pour n entendre non plus mais enfin
c'est vrai que c'était raccord avec
rouge et alors on vous voit on vous voit
à Strasbourg Fifi on vous voit à
versaill lors de la vente aux enchères
vous étiez le garde du corps de Serge
ouais je suis resté longtemps avec lui
ouais plusieurs années ouais mais
pourquoi il av besoin d'un garde du
corps ouais il y a eu beaucoup de
beaucoup de la de monace de beaucoup de
mecs qui ont voulu
l'agresser bon parce que ça plaisait pas
à tout le monde quoi mais alors il y a
une histoire magnifique quand ginbourg
achète le manuscrit de la Marseillaise
aux enchèr les images qu'on vient de
voir c'est que il raconte après ça
j'étais avec Fifi mon garde du corps qui
est d'origine polonaise c'est ça non ou
exct j'étais avec bambou qui est
d'origine chinoise moi je suis russe et
juif j'ai acheté le manuscrit de la
Marseillaise on est revenu de versaill
dans une voiture améri
américaine
formidable mais des fois c'est vrai que
ginsbourg quand il était un peu pété il
devait aussi casser les couilles de pas
mal de gens non euh un petit peu mais
bon c'était C faisit partie du
personnage je dire vous
vous é là aussi à ce moment-là pour le
pour le défendre ouais puis même le
défendre contre lui des fois ouais ouais
alors dans cet album qui s'appel aux
armes et cetera il y avait une autre
chanson qui s'appelle brigade des stupes
tout l'album a très très bien marché
l'album s'est vendu à plus d'un million
d'exemplaires ginbourg devient une super
St et il chantent aussi à la brigade des
stupes ils ont cherché mon spif et ils
ont trouvé mon PA et c'est Pierre Paul
Jacques qui nous chante
R
[Musique]
la je suis tombé sur les
cops ils ont cherché mon
spliff ils ont trouvé
mon à la brigade
tu un ancien
matave qui est complètement louve
oui toujour à
moitié et à la brigade
des il défixe la
chou j'ai les moules je
FPE c'est pas mon genre de
[Musique]
tri
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la tu
peux ce qui voulait c'est un
[Musique]
scancien demande un
autographe à la
[Musique]
brigade
il n'aim pas
l'IND non plus tu sais
ça à la briade
des je F que les
troupes je suis la
B
[Musique]
cinématographe o
nana oi
ni
[Musique]
oian
nana
[Musique]
lag c'est vrai que des fois j'y vais
faire un
tour vous croyez que j'aime
ça non moi je crois
pas pour les gagé connais
déjà ça va
ici bravo merci
asstoi pierrepjacques à la brigade des
stupes alors vous êtes le seul ce soir à
qui je demanderai pas pourquoi il a
choisi cette chanson B si tu peux y
aller alors pourquo une réponse c'est
quoi la réponse et ben parce
que parce que les les les les les
policiers m'ont arrêté dans la rue ouais
avec un avec un un petit join comme ça
et puis ils m'ont fait plein de tracas
et tout ça et en fait le le la
proposition de la chanson elle arrive en
même temps donc ouais bon moi je je je
connais pas très bien sa vie tout ça
mais ce que ce que je peux dire par
rapport au regget c'est que c'est quand
même comme ça que les les que beaucoup
de gens ont connu le réget et du FAO ENF
tu vois vrai de la Jamaïque qu merci
Fifi merci pierrejac merci à vous merci
beaucoup et voilà donc on va regarder
maintenant gbour parolier pour les
garçons mag
[Musique]
Jérôme
com
j resc là
c'est Plou Plou barbe
bousouin patate cludo fumier
crétinouou
[Musique]
ho disparu
ma tes jours c'est tes jours tu
dé
mais jamais jamais tu
n'arriveras là-bas
bambou dans tes silences se dessin
bambou tes africaines
saabicinent
bambou dans tes mutismes ton délire
bambou va de l'Angola
au Serge ginbourg parolier pour hom
nouveau parolier pour hom alors
dites-moi on vient de voir deux chansons
à l' Chan for bonsoir On vient voir deux
chansons sur une musique de vous parce
que là il faut dire que ce qu'on vient
de voir les musiques sont pas de sont
pas de ginsbourg immense tube quand même
Manua c'est vrai c'est vrai comment ça
se passait les séances en studio avec
Serge ben il y a eu des périodes
différentes sur Rock and rose il était
là extrêmement régulièrement très
présent très impliqué il avait beaucoup
travaillé on avait corrigé les textes
longuement et ca et puis après justement
il a connu cette période de de de
presque l'écriture automatique enfin ce
qu'il faisait pour et cetera ETF tout
cet album raid don venz de parler tout à
l'heure et donc il essaya d'appliquer
cette recette systématiquement avec tous
les gens avec lesquels il travaillait et
c'est ça qui me plaisait pas du tout
parce que moi j'avais envie
d' envie Deo s'entend oui bien alors
pour ginbourg une nouvelle époque va
commencer hein là c'est la fin des des
années régé c'est les années funky qui
gbourg devient ginbar c'est n funky
c'est malheureusement la dernière
période c'est 82
91 voilà on passe maintenant au dernier
tableau de la vie de Serge ginbourg
auteur compositeur interprète les années
funky 1982 1991 alors tout à l'heure
nous disait que lui il avait connu
ginsbourg effectivement il avait connu
ginbar parce qu'il est trop jeune pour
avoir connu ginsbourg et ouais c'est moi
ginzbar on me retrouve au hasard des
night club et des bars américains c'est
Bonard donc c'est lui qui a trouvé ce
double ce double ginsbar ginsbar qui lui
peut tout se permettre ginzbar c'est
celui qui va brûler le billet de 500
balles à la télévision ginzbar c'est
celui qui va dire à Whitney Houston sur
un plateau de mich drcker chez Drucker
il va dire à Whitney Houston i want to
fucker ce qu'il veut dire j'ai j'ai
envie de te baiser en clair j'ai envie
de la baiser il y a d'autres il y a
d'autres provoques comme ça g bar est
invité sur les plateaux de télévision
parce qu'on sait que quoi qu'il arrive
il va faire des score il va il va péter
l'udimat alors il y a deux albums à
cette époque il y a love on the Beat et
your under arrest et bah là là c'est
vraiment alors là il parle sur du rythme
c'est la la proseudition et puis alors
parfois et c'est le document qu'on va
voir maintenant il y a le ginzebar qui
s'exprime sur scène en disant des petits
poèmes par exemple Mickey maouse Micke
mous Magneto jérô Mickey maous
4 pieds si
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pouces qui fich
BL
rousse
j'ai
[Applaudissements]
Gour une paire de
pleous en avant tout et tous je pousse
maous extraordinaire pi il chante même
plus là il récite des poèmes il y en a
une autre chanson aussi qu'il récitait
sur scène c'était ma petite ququette
sort de ma braguette je pisse et je pète
en montant chez Kate moralité haut et
gaz à tous les étages oui il avait aussi
des beaucoup d'aphorismes ouais il avait
aussi des aphorismes alors ses
aphorismes préférés c'était qui promène
son chien est au bout de sa laisse ous
juste plus le snobisme ah ça c'est joli
le snobisme c'est une bulle de champagne
qui hésite entre le R et le PAI
magnifque l'amour est aveugle et sa
canne est rose c'est beau c'est mign qui
a coulé le titanque iceberg encore
unif quel est
votre comme ça vre souvenir V plus beau
souvenir avec Serge je crois que c'est
les chansons qu'on a fait ensemble et le
pire souvenir les pires souvenirs
euh c'est au retour de notre par exemple
notre séjour à Los Angeles quand on
avait écrit le disque amour annz zéro
euh sentir qu'il était plus solidaire
que c'était vraiment détaché qui m'avait
largué qui m'avait enfin je me suis
senti vraiment d'un seul coup plus rien
quoi c'estàd après avoir ressenti
quelque chose de très fort avec lui de
l'intimité de son confident et tout et
d'un seul coup j'ai j'ai été balayé d'un
d'un coup de rever comm ça pourquo
pourquoi je sais pas parce parce que lui
oui il passait autre chose puis il
aimait bien il avait besoin à ce
moment-là de de de de de laisser délirer
ce ce personnage ginzbar alors il a fait
une reprise ginsbourg c'est rare les
reprises chez ginsbourg c'est rare qui
qui chante les chansons des autres non
c'est arrivé une fois non oui c'était oh
deux ou trois fois c'était il avait
repris vieille canaille qui un standard
des années 40 il avait repris en et mon
légionnaire il a effectivement chanté
sur son dernier album studio il a de
reste mais avant ça il avait aussi fait
Love On The Beat et d'autres d'autres
tubes funky bon ben on va voir donc love
and the beat mon légionnaire Eton incest
Serge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gbourg je pense à toi en tant que cible
un bel enfant
écardele là j'ai touché le poisson si
attends je vais m'y
[Musique]
attarder
je sais pas son nom je ne sais rien de
lui il m'é toute la nuit
mon et me laant à mon destin il est
parti dans le matin plein de lumière il
était BCE il était beau il sentait mon
le sable chaud mon lé
jeun
Prine de
[Musique]
citron je t'aime
t je t'aime plus que
tout l'amour que N C jamais ensemble et
le NVE le plus violet le plus pur le
plus exquis
exqu
délicieux
enfants
ch voilà les M incest Serge ginbourg et
ginbourg pour finir alors Jane quelle
était votreaction parce que quand même
vous êtes vous étiez vous êtes la mère
de Charlotte quand vous voyez Serge qui
chante cette chanson lemon enest ça veut
dire inceste de de
citroni j'ai trouvé ça magnifique parce
que contrairement à tout ce qu'on
imaginer deun sorte de papa qui rodit
dans les appartements à poil et cetera
les enfants essayaient toujours de le
choper dans le baignoir ou de jamais
jamais moi-même je comme tout comme
bambou on s'est dit l'autre jour qu' on
l'avait jamais vu à poil c'était
quelqu'un qui était tellement délicat de
sa personne tellement complexe là-dessus
que jamais jamais ça me semblait
choquant pour rien au monde pour rien au
monde il aurait il aurait mis Charlotte
dans une situation chocante non pour lui
c'était une chanson d'amour
ouais c'est c'est l'époque où Serge
aborde un thème qu'il a jamais abordé
avant c'est l'homosexualité oui oui
c'est ça c'est sur l'album Love On The
Beat don voici la la pochette magnifique
photo de William clin où Serge choisit
d'apparaître en en travesti et il
utilise la même photos en travesti pour
annoncer ses concerts au Casino de Paris
avec ce slogan magnifique 140 francs
devant 110 francs derrière
gbour drôle et alors à l'époque Serge
ginsbourg reprenait souvent sur scène
des des chansons du début de son
répertoire c'est ce que font ce soir
lesita mitsoko avec l'hippopodame et au
revoir la champfor l'hippopotame verita
Mitsuko version
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
FKI c'est un Rubin c'est une
hpopodame
avec un DZ comme l'
marshmallow et si j'en pince pour si
poame c'est qu'avec elle j'ai des pris
de gros ah quelle suspense mon
hipopodame avec un B comme
dansasimolo les ressorts grinent sous
l'hippopodame mais au dessus je me sens
bien dans sa peau c'est pas une main ça
fait
[Musique]
hopodame avec un déé commean chicolo
quand elle me coince mon hippopodame
[Musique]
entre ces deux gros
aamacr puis elle sering qui fait
l'hippopodame avec un dé comme l' lavabo
elle redevient princesse hipopodame
elle me refile mon petit cadeau
[Musique]
oh
à quel suspense mon
hippopodame avec un décor
molo les ressorts grinent sous
l'hippopodame mais au-dessus je me sens
bien dans sa peau c'est pas une main d'
faire
sppopodame avec un D comme dans
gigolo quand elle me coince mon
hippopotame
entre ces deux gros et
MACR puis elle se Rin vite fait
hipopodame avec un décomme dans laavabau
elle revient princesse
hippopodame et me refile mon petit
cadeau c'est un Rubin c'est une
hipopodame avec un B comme dans
marshmallow si j'en pince pour si for po
d'armes c'est qu'avec elle j'ai des pris
de
[Musique]
gros
[Applaudissements]
mitso
l'opodame bonsoir bravo
mer
merci et bon ça fait
longtemps pourquoi cette chanson
pourquoi pas tu me diras non non enfin
oui je pourrais dire ça mais je pourrais
dire aussi que c'est une chanson que je
trouve excitante parce que même
personnellement l'idée de faire l'amour
avec une femme assez ronde avec des gros
seins et et de se perdre dans sa chair
c'est quelque chose qui moi m'aimeux
personnellement donc si tu veux j'ai
tendance à aimer la chanter alors c'est
un peu l'époque pour pour ser ça cette
époque là un peu l'époque de la descente
aux enfers de l'autodestruction oui y a
ginbourg GINB qui immensément populaire
il n'a jamais été aussi adulé adoré par
les petits gars et les petites pisseuses
comme comme il disait tous ces petit
fanatique qu'il adore qui vienent
l'applaudir en concert quand il se
produit au Casino de Paris quand il se
produit au zénites et dans le même temps
ginsbourg s'autodétruit c'est dû à quoi
Jane cette cette autodestruction
systématique écoute je ne sais je ne
sais pas quelqu'un je crois que c'était
Jacques Doyon m'a dit c'est une
suicidaire optimiste h pensait toujours
qu'il aurait un autre chance il y avait
des des médecins qui a dit qu'il fallait
arrêter de cloppper comme ça parce que
sinon ça finirait mal mais au même temps
euh on lui a donné des pilules qui
pouvaent prendre au même temps et
continuer de boire donc il avait
l'impression que si si il avait lu
quelque part que les empereurs romains
euh pouvaient bouffer boire autant qu'il
voulit et puis s' vomissait il pouvait
recommencer donc combien de fois euh
chez moi avec avec lui et bambou il ils
arrivaient et puis et puis il
recommençai enfin c'était comme des rien
à cette époque quand il faisait des des
cures deésintoxications pendant 2 mois
il était très en forme il était était
éblouissant il était comm comme soulagé
de euh du poids de l'alcoolisme mais
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit un suicidaire
optimiste je crois pas que enfin c'est
très difficile de savoir si les gens
savent si qu'ils vont mourir ou pas et
souvent ça me troublait de savoir s'il
le savait s'il savait pas de sil était
en détresse
ou quoi et et et je pense quelque part
qu'il pensait toujours qu'il aurait un
autre chance d'ailleurs la preuve était
qu'il il est il était dû partir le lundi
avec Philippe pour faire un disque il
avait s'il avait fait ça aurait fait 10
ans qu'il aurait fait le premier disque
Jaz depuis un long moment parce qu'il
avait l'intention de partir à nveau
orleéans où où Philippe avait fixé tous
les musiciens il m'appelé à Londres pour
me dire des paroles qu'il allait mettre
sur C chanson
pour le lundi pr n prochain styleoui et
là gbour va composer c'est une sorte de
de baroute d'honneur pour les fin pour
les plus belles filles de l'époque qui
va composer quelques chansons sublimes
et on commence avec jkin Maget
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jérô de
L
tes étoiles
éphémèes tu rêves
d'terité et là tu vas
laetouver tu n'es qu'un fumeur de
[Musique]
gitane et la dernière je
veux la voir brillè au fond de mes yeux
aime-moi nom de Dieu la pâ au fond de la
piscine que mes yeux sembl marine tu
lesava repéré sans qu'il y ait un regard
et
tavliqué maintenant je P les
[Musique]
faireetard avant de toucher le
fond je descends à
reculant sans trop savoir ce qui se
passait dans le
fond
enfant de
l'amour prait 15 pour
270 jours à ce jour plus j'ai lu dans
des grands yeux de feu
lourds dans
d'amour on me
dévisage on
m'envisage
comme une fille que je ne suis
pas je
m'exile trop
fragile il est uneile noig de moi dans
le moi je sa t même autant
d' parfois ça comme un
c toujours le même t
[Musique]
c'est bientô le
CH chanson pour jolie
femme cétait beau jusqu'à la fin et
maintenant la boucle va se boucler parce
que la dernière chanson qu'on va écouter
ce soir porte le nom de la boîte où le
père de Serge ginsbourg jouait et s'est
inspiré par Roman Kessel et ça s'appelé
aux enfants de la chance je vais d'abord
dire au revoir au Rita Mitsuko avant de
regarder AX r merci d'être venu Axel r
aux enfants de la
chance aux enfants de chance qui n'ont
jamais con TR
et des ch Dir en
substance touchez pas à la potière d'
ang
VO et disleur de casser la gueule
disleur qui de l'ombre attend
leurereur
[Musique]
de au enfants de la chance qui n'ont
jamais connu les temp
des en
substance comm pas prudance n surtout
pas l'UD de [__] l' avant le comme ça
monle et Disle de casser la gueule Disle
dans l'ombre
attendur
de
[Musique]
on la chance n jamais comme les TR des
chutes
deses en
substance n'approchez pas le Magic nessz
surtout pas le FL car celui qui vous
baisee
et
oui celui qui vous baise alla viur et
disleure de casser la gueule Disle de
l'ombre attend leur heure l' de
[Musique]
min
aux enfants de la chance qui n'ont
jamais connu les trans des
chutes des fites je dirais
[Musique]
substance touch pas au dragon chassing
chasse au dragon qui se prend en ch
ou en CH Z h
voilàle et disleure de casser la gueule
ou disleure que de l'ombre attend leure
heure
[Musique]
l'ombre
voilà
Accel aux enfants de la chance ainsi se
termine donc la première partie de cette
nuit ginsbourg bah je vrais remercier
d'abord évidemment toute l'équipe qui a
travaillé Gill verl et puis tous les
gens qui ont travaillé sur l'émission
Jane de sa présence tous les artistes
qui étaient avec nous ici ce soir pour
rendre hommage à Serge ginbourg et je
voudrais remercier Jean d'Angelo qui a
fait viens jean- viens Jean d'Angelo qui
a fait qui a fait toutes les
orchestrations des chansons vous avez
entendu ce
soir merci Jean merci
beaucoup voilà donc ben on va se
retrouver après les publicités pour la
deuxème partie donc comme je vous l'ai
dit qui est consacré à à Serge ginsbourg
auteur à Serge ginsbourg
peintre cinéast acteur séducteur night
clu enfin tout ce qu'on a pas vu dans
cette première partie Jane je vous
demander de me faire un cadeau de nous
faire un cadeau à tous j'aimerais que
vous nous chantiez la javanisee à
capella s'il vous
plaît j'avoue j'en ai bavé pas vous mon
amour avant d'avoir eu vent de vous mon
amour
ne vous
déplaise en dansant la
javanise nous n nous
aimions le temps
d'une
[Musique]
chanceons à votre avis qu'avons-nous vu
de l'amour de vous à moins vous m'aveis
eu mon
amour ne vous
déplaise en dansant la
javvanaise nous nous
aimions le temps
d'une
chanceant hélas avril en vain me vous à
l'amour j'avais envie de voir en vous
cet
amour ne vous
déplaise en dansant la
javanise nous n nous
aimions le temps
d'une
[Musique]
chanson la vie ne vaut d'être vécue sans
amour mais c'est vous qui l'avez voulu
mon
amour
ne vous
déplaise en dansant la
jaenè
nous nous
aimions le temps
d'une
chance
merci
merci voilà Serge si tu nous regardes
salut
one that's it
[Musique]
is that's
it
[Musique]
that's it
man
[Musique]
is
con
[Musique]
TUC